mes chers collègues je propose que
[Musique]
nous reprenions le cours de notre
commission
nous recevons aujourd'hui monsieur le
Président de la Fédération nationale des
syndicats d'exploitant agricoles la
FNSEA je vous remercie monsieur le
Président pour votre venue qui fait
suite à votre récente élection le 13
avril dernier à la tête de la FNSEA pour
évoquer avec notre commission et les
sénateurs de cette commission les grands
enjeux de l'agriculture française et
j'allais dire ce également qui sont liés
à l'agroalimentaire puisque tout ceci
est très lié l'actualité agricole
qu'elle soit européenne législatives et
je dirais médiatique étant
particulièrement riche depuis plusieurs
mois voire depuis plusieurs années votre
parole en tant que nouveau représentante
du principal syndicat agricole français
est attendu et ne manquera pas j'imagine
d'être commenté les sujets que nous
allons aborder ce matin sont cruciaux
ils sont complexes et ils sont souvent
extrêmement sensibles souverain
des thématiques centrales celles de
l'excès des normes de l'excès de charge
ou du besoin d'innovation au service de
la productivité de l'attractivité aussi
du métier d'agriculteur et enfin bien
sûr de la nécessaire transition
écologique certaines mesures ont eu un
écho particulier je pense au livret Agri
au diagnostic carbone mais aussi à
l'usage expérimental de drones au
pouvoir du ministre de l'Agriculture
vis-à-vis de l'ancêtre ou encore aux
enjeux de l'eau surtout cette PPA a
permis au Sénat de se positionner en
amont de l'examen prochain de la loi
d'orientation agricole qui sera sûrement
portée à l'automne par le gouvernement
ce sera donc mon interrogation est-ce
que vous adhérents qu'est-ce que vous
adhérents attendent de cette loi
d'orientation agricole quels sont les
leviers pour permettre une meilleure
transmission des exploitations agricoles
Faut-il rouvrir le vaste débat sur le
foncier agricole quelques mois après la
véritable entrée en vigueur de la loi
sans passe tous dont les décrets
d'applications ne sont intervenus que
la présentation attendue pour juillet
d'un vaste pacte vert qui impactera
profondément l'agriculture négociation
pour citer quelques impacts importants
négociations autour du règlement de
l'usage durable des pesticides pour
lequel la France vient de se positionner
en soutien au projet de la commission
sans toutefois souscrire à un certain
nombre d'amendements proposés par la
rapporteur notamment sur le relèvement
de la cible de réduction des pesticides
des plus dangereux d'ici 2030 ou encore
sur l'extension des ZT à 50 mètres
négociations houleuse autour de la
directive sur les émissions
industrielles qui risquent de très
durablement impacter l'élevage français
rejet inédit par la commission
agriculture du Parlement européen de la
proposition de règlement sur la
restauration de la nature au moment où
le président de la République a invité à
une pause réglementaire en matière de
normes environnementales ou bien
d'autres textes en cours d'élaboration
comme l'actualisation de la législation
sur le bien-être animal ou encore les
négociations autour des nouvelles
techniques d'édition génomiques comment
cet environnement législatif
réglementaire français européen
changeant impact notre agriculture et
l'impact qu'elles en sont les
opportunités qu'elles en sont les
risques si l'on veut rester positif ce
pacte vert ne pourrait être l'occasion
pour la France d'obtenir enfin des
résultats sur certains dossiers majeurs
à commencer par les fameuses clauses
miroirs apremment défendues ici au Sénat
et surtout les bancs surtout ces sujets
nous sommes impatients de vous entendre
je sais que mes collègues ne manqueront
pas de vous interroger à leur tour sur
les problématiques et l'avenir de notre
modèle agricole français si particulier
et qui convient alors où l'on redécouvre
les vertus de la souveraineté
alimentaire de protéger voire d'aider à
se développer voilà monsieur le
Président quelques premières questions
assez vastes je vais vous laisser la
parole et ensuite je laisserai la parole
à tous ceux qui souhaitent vous poser
des questions
en commençant par les trois rapporteurs
à l'agriculture auront du plonge
recrutisso et Françoise Ferrat monsieur
le Président c'est à vous
bien merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
de l'invitation qui m'est faite et je
voudrais évidemment saluer l'ensemble
des sénatrices et sénateurs de cette
commission nombreux et que je remercie
de l'intérêt qu'il porte à ce sujet qui
nous est cher et donc je sais que votre
commission régulièrement sans part
vous m'avez posé beaucoup de questions
dans la Présidente j'ai compris que
j'avais une quinzaine de minutes donc je
suis pas complètement sûr d'être en
mesure de répondre à la totalité de nos
interrogations mais j'essaierai en tous
les cas de d'éclairer le propos
peut-être si my autorisé un petit mot
introductif pour me présenter puisque
vous avez d'abord devant vous un
agriculteur
Seine-et-Marnais d'une région de grande
culture du bassin parisien une
exploitation que j'ai repris derrière
mes parents en 2002 qui était eux-mêmes
installé derrière leurs parents donc je
suis dans ce terroir du Multien qui est
le nord de l'abri depuis plusieurs
générations maintenant mon exploitation
est essentiellement tournée vers la
production de grandes cultures mais
également les légumes de plein champ et
depuis peu vers l'énergie c'est aussi
que vous avez à plusieurs reprises
aborder la thématique ici et notamment
me concernant la méthanisation
vous l'avez compris mais mes paires
m'ont élu à la présidence de l'AFPA il y
a maintenant près de d'un mois et donc
l'objet que je me propose d'évoquer
devant vous c'est l'ambition que nous
portons à l'intérieur de de ce syndicat
de ce corps intermédiaire dont il me
semble tout le monde a compris
maintenant l'intérêt
suite à ce qui s'est passé dans les
dernières années et et tout le rôle des
échanges et de la relation qu'on peut
avoir dans la construction du du
dialogue social alors je voudrais
peut-être
évoquer devant vous les quelques grandes
ambitions que nous avons portées dans le
cadre de la réaffirmation de notre
ambition la première c'est évidemment la
souveraineté et souveraineté alimentaire
que je voudrais décliner alors
évidemment derrière ce mot je voudrais
te précis on dire que pour nous la
souveraineté c'est la capacité que la
France a demain à pouvoir assurer la
fourniture d'une alimentation de qualité
et en quantité pour de ses compatriotes
mais c'est aussi la place que la France
occupe en Europe et dans son
environnement immédiat et je pense
notamment à la Méditerranée au continent
africain dans lequel nous pensons que en
termes de co-construction on peut aussi
faire valoir un certain nombre de nos
atouts parce que la France à cette
chance particulière d'être un pays
ouvert sur 4 océans dans un bassin de
consommation européen important avec une
formation avec une expertise
scientifique parmi les plus reconnus au
monde et je crois des agriculteurs des
adultrices formés qui ont cette capacité
à produire je crois qu'on a trop
tendance à l'oublier et finalement de
pouvoir bénéficier à l'échelle de la
planète de ces conditions de production
est une chance dont nous considérons que
probablement nous n'en n'avons pas assez
conscience alors cette compétitivité je
vous l'ai dit elle est une compétitivité
ouverte ça n'est pour nous ni l'autarcie
ni sur soi même si en terme de
production on peut avoir dans un certain
système de production des intérêts à une
grande mais en tous les cas la vision de
notre souveraineté est une souveraineté
qui ne renonce pas aux échanges et aux
commerces et si vous m'ont donné
l'occasion je vous dirai ce que je pense
de la balance commerciale des produits
agricoles qui sont en chute libre alors
même qu'elle était un des rares éléments
contributifs au grand déficit de la
balance commerciale de notre pays il
nous reste encore un peu les vins et
spiritueux quelques produits laitiers un
peu de céréales mais nous avons
largement perdu des parts de marché
derrière le mot souveraineté il y avait
évidemment le sujet de la compétitivité
et là aussi je voudrais essayer de
prendre quelques minutes pour vous
expliquer que quand on regarde ce qu'est
la ferme France et ce qui se passe dans
la ferme France depuis une vingtaine
d'années sur bien des plans nous sommes
en recul sur le plan de la production ça
a été dit sur le plan de la création de
valeur ajoutée sur le plan aussi des
échanges vient parler de la balance
commerciale voilà tout un tas de
facteurs qui nous interroge sur le
position à la fois l'agriculture et donc
sur notre propre
positionnement en termes de vision et de
déploiement mais aussi sur l'intérêt de
la nation pour la production agricole et
alimentaire alors il se trouve que les
récents événements si je puis dire que
sont le covid puis le retour de la
guerre sur le continent européen ont
remis sur le plan sur les premiers plans
dirais-je l'intérêt de garantir de
compatriotes une alimentation de
proximité de qualité de naturalité parmi
j'aime à le rappeler et je veux le faire
ici absolument une agriculture reconnue
comme étant parmi les plus durable au
monde alors je sais pas si si on est
numéro 1 et on va être co-cardé mais en
tous les cas l'agriculture française
à l'échelle internationale est reconnue
comme une agriculture de grande qualité
en termes de durabilité donc je parle
bien du plan économique environnemental
et sociale et si je le dis c'est parce
que on a parfois un peu en France dans
les débats qui sont les nôtres le
sentiment que la prise de conscience de
la qualité de cette agriculture n'est
pas toujours au rendez-vous je veux le
dire aussi dans la compétition mondiale
une quinzaine de pays dans le monde sont
en capacité de projeter de pouvoir
fournir de l'alimentation en plus de ce
qu'ils ont eux-mêmes besoin quand je dis
une quinzaine c'est d'ailleurs plutôt
une dizaine alors tout le monde a une
production locale voilà bdpi qui sont
capables de fournir durablement des
produits laitiers des céréales de
l'huile de la viande enfin les grands
produits nécessaires sont finalement
pas si nombreux et derrière la
souveraineté il y a évidemment les
intérêts de la nation et je veux dire un
tout petit mot des aspects de
géopolitique et de géostratégie alors à
l'échelle européenne puisque quand on
parle d'agriculture on est très
rapidement à l'échelle européenne mais
après tout on voit bien que les grands
blocs mondiaux je parle des États-Unis
je parle de la Chine
sont en train de regarder ce qu'est la
question alimentaire et comment cette
question est aussi une arme de soft
power pour le moment je dis pour le
moment parce que vous voyez bien que le
conflit en Russie entre la Russie et
l'Ukraine à immédiatement eu des impacts
en termes de marché nous avons atteint
des prix de céréales inédits peut
supportable d'ailleurs pour la plupart
des consommateurs et des enjeux
évidemment immédiats à la fois de
logistique mais aussi vous avez vu sur
le continent africain la bataille qui se
perd pour notamment alimenter en
céréales et donc on voit bien que
derrière des aspects qui pourraient
apparaître comme étant technique les
grands enjeux de sécurisation et de
garantie d'une forme de paix où en tous
les cas de vision stratégique sont
évidemment essentiels et si la question
énergétique est apparue très rapidement
aux Français parce que les coûts de
l'énergie ont rapidement imposé des
réactions vives le coût de
l'alimentation à lui-même était
directement impactée l'alimentation a
augmenté de l'ordre de 16%. donc
l'histoire n'est pas une bataille sur
les chiffres mais de prendre conscience
que
dans cette histoire de compétitivité
nous avons eu en France dans les 10
dernières années et avant que les lois
égalim dont je sais qu'elles ont fait
l'objet de beaucoup de débats ici vous
l'avez rappelé madame la Présidente
quelque chose
d'insupportable pour les agriculteurs
avec de la déflation pendant près de 10
ans de la destruction de valeur de la
perte d'exploitation et de l'autre la
période que nous vivons où on observe
qu'un certain nombre de nos compatriotes
ne sont plus en capacité de se nourrir
on a vu que les baisses étaient
substantielles et que nombre aujourd'hui
de foyers y compris parmi les plus
modestes renonce parfois à se nourrir de
manière équilibrée et et plusieurs fois
par jour il y a aussi qu'à l'échelle de
la planète les sujets de malnutrition ou
d'absence de nutrition sont en train de
repartir c'était près du 800 millions de
personnes sur la planète qui n'avaient
pas accès à une nourriture de qualité et
en quantité
avec les l'apport journalier nécessaire
ce chiffre est en train d'augmenter on a
passé le milliard donc évidemment je
fais une transition tout trouver sur les
aspects du changement climatique on sait
qu'un certain nombre de pays vont être
confrontés et la France en sera et ce
d'entre vous qui sont élus du sud de la
France et je pense notamment aux
Pyrénées-Orientales ont vu depuis
quelques semaines ou quelques mois les
impacts des aspects du changement
climatique et je reviendrai sur la
question de l'eau donc cette
souveraineté elle ne peut pas aller sans
compétitivité elle ne peut pas aller son
moyen de production je voudrais en dire
un mot aussi parmi les moyens de
production il y a le foncier et donc
comment nous préservons la terre
agricole dans ce pays et comment nous
l'équilibrons entre les aspects
agricoles mais aussi les aspects
nécessaires de déploiement des activités
économiques de l'habitat et ne pas dire
mais je il se trouve que je suis élu
local d'une petite commune rurale comme
il en existe beaucoup en France
260 habitants et donc je vois bien les
équilibres et je sais que ici dans cette
maison les sujets autour du Zéro
artificialisation nette ont été sont
encore des sujets de discussion
et donc nous évidemment ce qui nous
importe c'est de trouver cet équilibre
d'abord pour défendre la terre agricole
puisque il y a eu énormément de
consommation et si on peut évidemment
faire un certain nombre de reproches à
l'agriculture sur la perte de
biodiversité sur les aspects tenants à
l'environnement évidemment quand on a de
l'artificialisation des sols agricoles
on peut dire que là pour le coup ce sont
des disparitions définitives mais
j'assume et nous assumons aussi de dire
la NSA que évidemment on vit dans un
écosystème dans lequel on a besoin de
pouvoir sur soi à la construction à
l'aménagement au déploiement des
services publics à tout ce qui fait que
la cité a besoin de le faire en revanche
on considère comme c'est trop souvent le
le cas dans les documents d'urbanisme
que la terre agricole n'est pas une
forme de réserve ou un puits sont fond
dans lequel on aurait le moyen de
déployer l'urbanisation il faut qu'on le
fasse de manière équilibrée et on sait
aussi que sur le plan sociétal parfois
le partage de l'espace peut être objet
de crispation ou de tension donc on a
besoin d'être vigilant sur ce point sur
les moyens de production il y a la
question de l'eau qui est une question
de plus en plus centrale sur lequel le
débat c'est un peu exacerbé notamment
autour des du sujet des réserves de
Poitou-Charentes que certains appellent
les méga bassines je voudrais vous
donner quelques chiffres parce que j'ai
parfois le sentiment que tout le monde
n'a pas forcément conscience des enjeux
il pleut de l'ordre de 500 milliards de
mètres cubes par an en France
le réchauffement climatique n'a pas
fondamentalement bougé les chiffres un
peu moins depuis deux ans mais
globalement c'est de l'ordre de 500
milliards de mètres cubes par an de
réellement utilisable c'est environ 200
milliards de mètres cubes le reste étant
le cycle de l'eau pour ceux qui se
souviennent de leur cours de collège et
le prélèvement sur le milieu et de un
peu supérieur à 30 milliards entre 31 et
32 milliards
l'agriculture prélève elle 3,2 milliards
de mètres cubes par an donc voilà 500
200 prélèvements 32 pour l'agriculture
c'est 3,2 milliards de mètres cubes par
an je voudrais dire que l'agriculture en
prélevait 4,5 en 2000 donc elle a déjà
réduit très sensiblement son impact et
c'est une bonne chose de près de 30%
depuis 2000 et qu'avec un mètre cube
d'eau aujourd'hui on s'est produire de
l'ordre de 30% de biomasse
supplémentaire
ça c'est l'eau prélevé l'eau réellement
consommé c'est de l'ordre pour
l'agriculture toujours de 2,8 milliards
de mètres cubes les chiffres que je vous
donne sont les chiffres du du ministère
de l'Écologie
et donc ce qui fait débat c'est parfois
la période de prélèvement et notamment
la question du maïs qui défrait la
chronique mais si ça vous intéresse je
vous expliquerai que le maïs en termes
de matière produite par au consommer et
finalement une plante intéressante en
tous les cas ce qu'il nous faut c'est
assurer la continuité et je le dis parce
que demain dans la capacité que nous
aurons collectivement à relever le
challenge de la réduction de l'émission
des gaz à effet de serre dans lequel
l'agriculture a une responsabilité et
culture c'est de l'ordre de 20% des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre en
France qui elle-même représente 0,9% des
émissions mondiales
nous considérons que nous avons donc une
responsabilité pour contribuer à cela et
pour réduire de même nos émissions il
faudra que nous produisions de la
biomasse et produire de la biomasse il
faut de l'énergie c'est la photosynthèse
mais il faut aussi de l'eau soit de
l'eau qui tombe du ciel soit de l'eau
qui est stockée d'où le combat que nous
menons pour le stockage de l'eau et je
le dis on est parfois un peu
décontenancé par le caractère
déraisonnable de la discussion autour de
ces sujets la question du stockage de
l'eau est une question très ancienne
très ancienne
voilà les Grecs les Romains avaient déjà
ce sujet et dans le cas de la
planification écologique ce que nous
avons demandé c'est qu'on puisse
réfléchir de manière apaisée à la
question du stockage de l'eau qui
peut-être d'ailleurs un stockage partagé
il n'y a pas que les sujets agricoles
nous en avons conscience
qui peut-être un stockage donc
multi-usage très différents en fonction
des endroits où on se situe en France et
la problématique de Poitou-Charentes
n'est pas qui est plat n'est pas du tout
avec un planimétrie faible n'est pas du
tout la même que celle qu'on pourrait
trouver dans d'autres dans d'autres
territoires on peut avoir des tailles
diverses avec des projets
collectifs ou plus plus concentré mais
en tous les cas avec ce que nous disent
aujourd'hui les hydrogéologues et les
météorologues on aura des pluviométries
plus ératiques et on aura donc besoin de
mieux stocker l'eau et de faire en sorte
qu'on la partage mieux je n'ignore pas
que dans un certain nombre de territoire
l'accès à l'eau est devenu beaucoup plus
compliqué je pense notamment à votre
département madame ou dans les
Alpes-Maritimes les sujets de l'eau sont
très compliqués en ce moment et
notamment laduction d'eau potable mais
on a besoin en tous les cas de se poser
ce sujet de manière un peu des
passionnée
et quand on évoque un modèle
productiviste moi je veux rappeler
devant vous que l'agriculture française
est plurielle et que les modèles sont
très différents en fonction des
territoires et des régions dans lesquels
on se situe je reviendrai sur la
question de l'eau je voudrais dire un
mot évidemment dans les moyens de
production ça les produits
phytosanitaires
sur lequel on dit beaucoup de choses on
prêt beaucoup de choses à l'iPhone et
soit je voudrais être assez précis
devant vous aujourd'hui on ne sait pas
être en capacité de produire en quantité
et en qualité sans se passer d'un
certain nombre de produits
phytosanitaires qui soient de synthèse
ou qu'il soit naturel
est-ce que ça veut dire qu'on renonce au
fait d'améliorer et de tendre vers le
zéro Phyto la réponse est non et je
voudrais rappeler ici les efforts qui
ont été faits à la fois sur les produits
les plus dangereux qu'on appelle CM1 qui
ont disparu pour 87% d'entre eux et sur
les cmr2 qui ont déjà baissé est-ce
qu'on peut aller plus loin la réponse
est oui la question c'est la trajectoire
et c'est l'investissement qui nous
permet de ne pas nous retrouver en
situation d'impasse et ce que porte la
FNSEA c'est le refus de se trouver en
situation d'impasse et singulièrement en
France vous le savez les produits
phytosanitaires ont des homologations
européennes et des autorisations de mise
en marché nationale et si un produit
pose des problèmes de santé publique ou
d'autres natures il est en France il est
évidemment en Allemagne et en Italie et
donc le retrait de certaines molécules
en France et pas ailleurs évidemment
nous questionne dans un cadre de
compétitivité puisque c'est mon propos
qui permettra à nos voisins de
bénéficier de moyens dont nous ne
disposons pas et je veux rappeler ici
puisque j'en dis un mot tout à l'heure
que sur les importations évidemment nos
concurrents les plus féroces ne sont pas
à l'autre bout de la planète mais sans
nos voisins immédiat à l'intérieur de
l'Europe
je poursuis mon propos je voudrais vous
parler aussi de la recherche de
l'innovation et notamment puisque il y a
un sujet pendant ce moment à Bruxelles
autour des nouvelles techniques de
sélection que dans un cadre qui a besoin
évidemment d'être clairement défini avec
des questions d'éthique d'encadrement du
brevetage du vivant mais nous avons
besoin demain de pouvoir continuer à
bénéficier du progrès comme
l'agriculture on a bénéficié depuis
plusieurs années non pour nous vendre à
quelques grandes firmes ou pouvoir
renoncer à une forme d'équilibre et je
le dis pour un agriculteur l'équipe ce
sera toujours l'agronomie donc des choix
opérés en fonction des saisons des
situations et des territoires mais nous
avons besoin de pouvoir bénéficier
demain de techniques qui nous
permettront d'accélérer je veux le dire
ici je parle de mutagenèse et non de
transgenèse donc on parle pas
d'organismes génétiquement modifié on
parle bien de de muta Genèse voilà
[Musique]
une petite TPE entreprise de l'artisanat
du commerce fait en sorte que encore une
fois ils vivent de son produit et c'est
tout le combat qui avait été mené sur
egalim et le fait que on renonce à cette
déflation ce qui est le cas depuis un an
même si encore probablement des choses à
améliorer mais en tous les cas c'est le
cas vous savez aujourd'hui l'agriculture
et la classe socioprofessionnelle qui
travaille le plus par semaine c'est 55
heures par semaine de travail en moyenne
un peu plus dans l'élevage et donc ça me
fera ma transition avec mon deuxième
point si nous voulons demain attirer
des jeunes générations des talents
j'irai comme tous les secteurs
d'activités économiques de ce pays à un
moment où c'est plus difficile de les
trouver il faudrait évidemment qu'on y
mette un peu d'attractivité or expliquer
demain un jeune ou une jeune
agricultrice que il va choisir un
engagement pour une vie pour une partie
de sa vie avec un engagement de capitaux
qui sont lourds l'agriculture et le plus
faible secteur avec la rentabilité des
capitaux si vous expliquez ça un bon
pied ou un industriel
il quitte la pièce sur le champ la
rentabilité des capitaux employés en
agriculture c'est de l'ordre de 1 à 2%.
c'est plutôt entre 6 et 7 dans le
commerce et artisanat plutôt vise dans
l'industrie et plutôt au dessus de 20
dans les services voilà bon donc employé
des sommes conséquentes pour s'installer
pour acheter un cheptel un hangar un peu
de matériel agricole une serre que
sais-je voilà nécessite des capitaux
importants avec une rentabilité faible
un travail important par semaine et
parfois des doutes sur la reconnaissance
de la Nation et bien écoutez vous avez
là une équation pour lequel nous nous
avons envie de nous battre parce que
nous pensons que d'abord ces métiers du
sens que nourrir nos compatriotes trois
fois par jour ça donne du sens qu'on
peut le faire qu'on peut le faire
manière qualitative qu'on est inscrit
dans les transitions
que évidemment on s'adaptera à la
demande du consommateur d'une demande de
plus grande proximité naturalité mais
qu'il faut aussi veiller à ce que selon
les équipes économiques je voudrais
rappeler ici que les achats se font
principalement dans le cadre de la
grande distribution que le covid avait
permis
notamment aux exploitations tournées
vers l'avant-directe de connaître une
embellie importante qui nous avait donné
quelques exploits et qui sait noyer si
je puis dire avec le retour d'une vie
plus normalisée donc on a besoin
évidemment d'attirer et des talents je
voudrais vous dire que l'agriculture
cherche en ce moment de l'ordre de 70000
collaborateurs qui peuvent être
potentiellement demain les nouveaux
installés et que on a du mal à les
trouver et pour autant nos métiers
offrent aujourd'hui un plus grand
confort d'exécution en tous les cas une
pénélité au travail moins importante
mais c'est vrai que on a aujourd'hui en
agriculture une pénibilité plutôt plus
importante que la moyenne des métiers
que c'est une vie voilà essentiellement
extérieur avec des conditions parfois
ruines mais en tous les cas une
amélioration de ces conditions et donc
on a besoin de travailler sur ce
renouvellement des générations nous
reste un peu moins de 420 000
exploitations professionnelles on
considère que sans 62 à 175000
agriculteurs vont partir en retraite
dans les 5 à 7 ans et que évidemment si
on veut renouveler les talents et faire
en sorte qu'on continue à avoir
l'exploitation qui mâle le territoire et
qui crée de la dynamique de territoire
on a évidemment besoin d'attirer des
jeunes alors il y a quelques bonnes
nouvelles notamment ce qu'on observe
dans les lycées professionnels et dans
la formation agricole qui a repris qui a
repris des couleurs depuis maintenant
quelques années mais il faut qu'on soit
capable de le faire nous avons
d'ailleurs commis un rapport
d'orientation cette année à la FNSEA
pour dire aussi notre intérêt
d'accueillir de nouveaux talents on
pense que dans les installations des 10
prochaines années on aura de l'ordre
d'un quart d'exploitant issus du monde
mais que pour trois quarts d'entre eux
ils seront ce qu'on appelle des nimas
pardonnez-moi cette acronyme et des
nones issus du milieu agricole
c'est-à-dire des gens qui embrassent ce
métier parce qu'encore une fois ils y
trouvent du sens avec des productions
qui peuvent être encore une fois très
différentes nous avons intérêt à
accueillir ces gens à leur expliquer
comment
on peut les aider dans leur projet
professionnel avec une mission de la
FNSEA qui était redéfinie redéfini et
qui est s'engager avec les femmes et les
hommes qui ont le goût d'entreprendre en
agriculture pour des territoires vivants
et dynamiques et vous retrouvez le
triptyque évidemment de la place de
l'homme et de la femme parce que
l'agriculture ça restera toujours une
activité d'hommes et de femmes quel que
soit par ailleurs la mécanisation et la
modernisation et l'innovation le
deuxième chose c'est le goût
d'entreprendre parce que on considère
que quel que soit là encore une fois la
taille du projet c'est quand même un
moment quelqu'un qui fait le choix de le
de se lancer dans l'entreprise Fustel
toute petite mais ça veut dire la
connaissance de son écosystème de ses
clients de ses partenaires qui soient
financiers institutionnels voilà la
capacité à trouver aussi du financement
pour développer les projets pour être
accompagnés pour se former continuer la
formation pour bénéficier de l'expertise
de ceux qui ont déjà eu une expérience
et donc ça on a besoin de le faire donc
ce combat de l'installation il est
important et on a besoin de relever le
troisième point est j'en terminerai par
là et évidemment je me tiens disponible
pour répondre à vos questions le
troisième point que nous portons c'est
la nécessité qu'on a de recréer un
dialogue avec avec l'ensemble de la
société ce que nous constatons à regret
c'est que il y a encore 10 ou 20 ans la
plupart de nos compatriotes avaient un
lien avec l'agriculture plus ou moins
directe un cousin un oncle un grand-père
voilà aujourd'hui un certain nombre des
Français ne savent plus rien de
l'agriculture
plus rien sur le rythme des saisons plus
rien sur l'élevage voilà et que
et que évidemment il faut que nous
réexpliquons l'intérêt qu'on a conservé
une agriculture de production qui ne
veut pas dire productiviste par ailleurs
mais qui continue à produire et si je le
dis c'est parce que les chiffres de
l'importation depuis 5 ans nous alarmes
nous importons mais vous le savez on le
répète à tour de bras nous importons
aujourd'hui une part de plus en plus
importante de nolder alimentation 40%
nos légumes 60% de nos fruits 50% de nos
poulets 25% de notre viande bon vide 50%
de notre viande et je pourrais continuer
et évidemment
au regard de ce que je vous ai dit on ne
peut pas on ne peut pas durablement
projeter l'agriculture si à un moment on
ne porte pas une vision durable de cette
agriculture et donc
demain la capacité que les agriculteurs
auront à répondre et c'est ce que nous
voulons expliquer la société au grand
challenge du changement climatique de la
restauration de la biodiversité dans
lequel l'agriculture des 30 dernières
années a une responsabilité si on veut
continuer à fournir une alimentation de
qualité de proximité à des prix
abordables pour le consommateur si on
veut défendre notre modèle social auquel
on tient c'est-à-dire ne pas faire en
permanence la courte échelle les
agricultures du reste du monde sur
lesquels les conditions de production ne
sont pas les celles qu'on nous demande
alors on a besoin de redéfinir le projet
politique et de l'expliquer à l'ensemble
de nos compatriotes je le dis parce que
le temps nous est compté je j'observe
que la puissance publique aujourd'hui
parle beaucoup de réindustrialisation ce
qui signifie que nous nous sommes
trompés collectivement il y a une
trentaine d'années en considérant que
peut-être d'autres produiraient plus
vite mieux et à moindre coût que ce que
nous étions capables de faire en France
et puis la fin d'une forme de
multilatéralisme et le retour d'une
forme de tension nous montre que nous
avons abandonné dépend entier de notre
souveraineté nous ne sommes pas là en
agriculture nous avons encore les moyens
de transition pour autant que on le
réaffirme et de ce point de vue là et je
voudrais en terminer
ce que le Sénat apporté dans le cadre de
la PPL alors je veux pas aborder les 26
articles mais en tous les cas bien des
égards nous convient et c'est ce que
nous porterons d'abord dans le pacte
qui est en préparation avec le ministre
de l'agriculture et dans les débats
région qui viennent de s'achever et pour
répondre là aussi à la question que vous
m'avez posée madame la Présidente sur le
cadre de la loi aujourd'hui sur le
portage notamment du foncier nous sommes
prêts à discuter parce que c'est un vrai
enjeu de renouvellement des générations
et donc j'essaie d'être cohérent avec ce
que je viens de vous dire avant en
revanche il nous semble important de de
cadrer les choses et de faire en sorte
que si la loi est parfois nécessaire on
fasse attention à pas multiplier les
règlements je voudrais quand même le
dire puisque je suis devant le
législateur nombre aujourd'hui de nos
agriculteurs ne s'y retrouvent plus dans
la multiplication des règlements et de
tout ce qui encadrent et ce que je peux
vous dire de manière très concrète c'est
que aujourd'hui ça tombe de contrôle
sont diligées sur le terrain et c'est
normal quand il y a des politiques
publiques et que donc nos fédérations
organisent des accompagnements ou des
prêts contrôles et que aujourd'hui à peu
près 90% des prêts contrôle qui sont
opérés
relève des des erreurs ou alors des
erreurs de bonne foi dirigent en tous
les cas des non-respects de la
réglementation qui pourraient conduire à
de la verbalisation alors voilà ce que
je vais vous dire aussi c'est qu'un
certain agriculteurs ont baissé les bras
de ne comprennent plus qu'on leur
demande et que ils ont besoin encore une
fois peut-être qu'on leur signifie
quelle est la trajectoire quelle est
l'étoile du Bergerac si je puis dire et
faire en sorte que pour ce qui est
encore une fois nécessaire le règlement
le cadre et ça nous protège on puisse
simplifier je vous appelle utiliser ce
mot parce qu'à chaque fois qu'on nous
explique qu'on va simplifier ça se passe
pas toujours bien mais en tous les cas
voilà l'idée qu'on poursuit
je m'arrête on vous disant que
évidemment la FNSEA est disponible
partout où il y a besoin de porter cette
ambition qu'on accepte évidemment de se
faire challenger qu'on fait pas tout
bien
qu'on est en train de bouger très
largement sur ce qui a été notre
histoire collective des 70 dernières
années mais que notre volonté évidemment
c'est donner de l'ambition et que
notamment
cette ambition elle doit elle doit
parler aux hommes aux femmes ce qui a
été le rapport de la Cour des comptes la
semaine dernière a été une blessure j'ai
eu l'occasion de le dire la première
ministre me semble-t-il à clôturer le
débat hier en tous les cas pour ce qui
est de la position du rap de ce fameux
rapport de la Cour des comptes mais
voilà vous pouvez pas au quotidien aller
travailler porter l'ambition de produits
alimentation de qualité quand la nation
ne vous donne pas le signe que vous êtes
attendu et encore une fois des efforts
seront consentis dans le cadre des
émissions dans le cadre de la
biodiversité dans le cadre des attentes
sociétales mais il y a besoin de donner
d'énergie et c'est aussi le message que
je suis venu vous délivrer ce matin
merci beaucoup pour votre attention très
bien merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président je vais donner la parole
d'abord aux trois rapporteurs vous
pourrez leur répondre ou réagir sur
leurs propos et ensuite je donnerai la
parole au très nombreux collègues qui se
sont inscrits et par conséquent vous me
verrez dans l'obligation de réduire le
temps de prise de parole
y compris pour Monsieur Duplomb qui va
attaquer qui va attaquer cette
dans les rapporteurs
faute de vous décevoir j'avais pas
spécialement prévu de parler mais vu que
vu que vous me laissez vous vous me
laissez la possibilité vous me tendez la
perche bien sûr que je vais la prendre
avec avec plaisir
remercier Arnaud des propos qui
deviennent tenir je pense que pendant
des années pendant trop d'années pendant
ces dernières années nous avons
eu trop de messages discordant je pense
que nous avons eu trop d'égarements et
qu'aujourd'hui les événements que nous
avons connu tels que le covid tel que la
guerre en Ukraine malheureusement nous
ont fait redécouvrir
des images qui existaient bien avant ces
dernières décennies mais nous ont fait
surtout toucher du doigt des enjeux
stratégiques pour notre pays je pense
qu'aujourd'hui l'agriculture française
a deux objectifs principaux à retrouver
le premier la souveraineté pour éviter
le risque de la sécurité alimentaire
parce que nous en sommes là et le
deuxième se donner les moyens par la
compétitivité de ne pas sombrer dans
cette problématique de souveraineté et
de sécurité alimentaire
pendant trop d'années que ce soit les
ministres ou même ceux qui ont défendu
l'agriculture ils n'avaient pas de Cape
clair et une multitude d'attaques
faisant l'occupation journalière et de
répondre à ces attaques faisant oublier
l'objectif principal retrouver celui-là
retrouvez celui de la souveraineté et de
la compétitivité basons nous par rapport
à cela sur tous les défis qui nous
attendent sur ces deux objectifs et je
peux vous garantir que non seulement en
redonnera la fierté à notre réécriture
française mais surtout on redonnera de
la fierté à nos agriculteurs
merci Laurent
voilà je reconnais ton compter merci
Jean-Claude Tissot ensuite Françoise
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président
avant de vous poser mes questions
permettez-moi de vous présenter toutes
mes félicitations pour votre élection on
avait pas le temps de débattre même si
vous êtes venus déjà dans mon
département c'était votre première
sortie je crois dans le département de
la Loire mais je pouvais pas être
présent je sais plus pour quelle raison
mais je m'étais excusé auprès de votre
président
ma première question portera sur votre
position sur le texte que nous venons de
travailler ici au Sénat sur la
compétitivité de la ferme France dans
mon territoire mon département je le
disais la Loire et en tant que cancer de
l'agriculteur du groupe et je côtoie
évidemment des collègues des
agriculteurs dont certains évidemment
bien sûr sont syndiqués à la Finse et
qui ont des exploitations en disant de
taille raisonnable
bien souvent en dessous de la moyenne
nationale qui est 60-70 hectares dans
mon département c'est 57 hectares en
région aura ses 59 hectares
et à ma lecture un autre lecture cette
proposition de loi fut d'une grande part
des dispositions proposées dans ce texte
n'allait pas dans les mêmes pas les
concerner si j'ose dire je pense
notamment à l'augmentation des plafonds
de la DEP car le ciblage du texte a été
essentiellement fait on en a expliqué
longuement pendant ces débat
a été essentiellement fait sur les
grandes exportations et les grandes
structures et je me constituonne donc
sur le regard extérieur que vous pouvez
porter sur l'accompagnement de tous ces
agriculteurs qui ont des petites
exploitations et qui finalement forment
une base importante de votre syndicat et
qui sont finalement à travers ce texte
me semble-t-il même pas écouter d'autant
et là c'était aussi une surprise quand
on a vu le récent décret je crois que
c'est le 13 mai sur le statut de
l'agriculteur actif qui est quand même à
nouveau une porte ouverte à une
financiarisation sans limite de notre
agriculture avec un risque et je le
pense vraiment avec des investisseurs
qui vont venir de toutes parts et donc
apparemment la rédaction se décrit vous
avez soutenu cette rédaction donc
j'aimerais avoir votre avis plus
directement là dessus quel message
comptez-vous à travers ce texte porté
envers ces agriculteurs là et puis ma
deuxième question est un sujet que vous
connaissez parfaitement c'est sur le
comme tous les autres d'ailleurs sur
l'énergie mais je voudrais aborder la
grivevoltaïs mais j'avais posé déjà
cette question à votre prédécesseur
Christiane Lambert à l'occasion d'un
petit déjeuner ici travail et j'avais
pas une réponse claire donc je vous la
repose moi il y a alors je me suis
opposé
je suis plutôt plutôt généralement
consensuel mais là la grivevoltaïsme
fait peur et j'avais posé une question
assez directe et assez claire que
pensez-vous de la concurrence déloyale
qui pourrait s'installer avec ses
productions là la cryvoltaïs avec le
statut du fermage
et ça je crains vraiment que
ce soit un petit peu un miroir aux
alouettes ou alors au nom véritablement
ça sera une opportunité pour certains
agriculteurs mais au détriment justement
finalement l'objectif que vous
recherchez la souveraineté alimentaire
et la concurrence des terres agricoles
il était dévoluent à l'énergie voilà je
serai pas plus long merci Jean-Claude
Françoise Ferrat merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Président puisque
nous en sommes aux invitations vous
seriez le bienvenu dans mon département
la Marne
on va attendre le champagne je n'osais
pas le dire ça va de soi Monsieur le
Président vous avez abordé le sujet de
l'eau la sécheresse celle qui nous
poursuit toujours plus forte et le
nécessaire est difficile équilibre à
trouver entre les ressources et les
besoins moi je voudrais apporter un
complément à vos propos en vous
questionnant sur la désalinisation de
l'eau de mer et la réutilisation des
eaux usées quel est votre avis sur ces
deux points
et puis la surtance position est un
sujet qui revient dans toutes les
rencontres dans toutes les conversations
que nous pouvons avoir ici et ailleurs
et je trouve que notre pays se distingue
dans ce domaine
et l'arbitrage politique prend souvent
le pas sur le bon sens et l'intérêt de
l'agriculture je crois d'autres pays se
sont posés cette question et il ressort
que la majorité des États affiche une
part de norme européenne plus faible que
la nôtre alors je ne parle pas de ceux
qui ne respectent pas l'énorme bien
entendu mais je vais vous donner
quelques exemples
moi 14% au Danemark moi 10% d'Autriche
-39% en Allemagne qui elle pratique le
when out alors pour ceux qui ne savent
pas ce que ça veut dire mais ça
m'étonnerait c'est ce système de
compensation qui est quelquefois discuté
voir discutable quel est votre avis sur
ce point et vous dire également en ce
qui concerne l'enseignement agricole
c'est un sujet sur lequel je suis
particulièrement sensible puisque j'ai
rapporté le budget pendant 16 années
je suis parfaitement d'accord avec vous
il faut vraiment que cet enseignement
colle le plus possible aux besoins
d'aujourd'hui vous l'avez évoqué et la
montée en compétence qui est absolument
nécessaire
et je pense que le personnel les
agriculteurs mieux formés seront en plus
grande capacité d'aborder leur quotidien
je ne reviens pas sur ce que vous avez
dit évidemment et que nous que nous
connaissons parfaitement je pense ainsi
qu'on pourrait peut-être s'éviter une
détresse toujours plus grande au niveau
de nos agriculteurs merci
non je vais peut-être vous laisser
réagir et répondre à nos trois
rapporteurs merci madame la Présidente
[Musique]
je
partage votre sentiment sur le nécessité
de renouveler à la fois la souveraineté
la compétitivité je l'ai dit moi je ne
positionne pas les priorités je pense
qu'elles sont dans ce que je vous ai
exposées elles sont un tout je veux dire
ici que si on restaure la souveraineté
et qu'on restaure la compétitivité mais
que on n'a pas les agriculteurs et les
agricules pour pour faire le le travail
on n'aura pas forcément gagné la partie
donc c'est c'est vraiment un tout et le
contexte je le dis est aussi important
en tous les cas moi je tenais avec
l'ensemble des administrateurs de la
FNSE à remercier le travail que vous
avez porté avec d'autres il a au moins
le mérite de mettre le débat sur la
table sur vos questions monsieur
sénateur alors voilà il faitsea on
oppose pas
les tailles de production et les tailles
d'exploitation et les types
d'exploitation pour une simple raison
c'est que vous parliez la moyenne des
exploitations dans votre département
mais chez moi c'est plus du quintuple la
moyenne voyez-vous parce que le biotope
n'est pas le même la planimétrie n'est
pas la même et pour avoir eu la chance
de me rendre dans votre département à la
fois pour discuter avec un éditeur mais
aussi pour aller sur des exploitations
dans les mondes du Lyonnais j'ai vu la
diversité de votre département et par
conséquent je veille toujours à ce que
les problématiques ne soient pas fait à
l'aune de la taille des exploitations
mais bien à l'aune de l'ambition qui est
portée et donc je voudrais vous répondre
notamment sur le sujet des agriculteurs
actifs
c'est un débat porté d'ailleurs à la
FNSEA par quelqu'un qui est de votre
territoire Bertrand Lapalu en
l'occurrence qui porte cette ambition de
la définition de l'agriculture actif
pour qu'on veille à ce que justement on
n'est pas demain des gens qui puissent
bénéficier de la politique agricole
commune de la pacte qui ne soit que des
donneurs d'ordre et pas en tant que tel
agriculteur c'est le cas notamment en
Italie ce que nous avons porté nous
c'est un certain nombre de points on
avait même à l'iPhone était porté une
volonté jusqu'à l'âge et qui n'a pas été
reconnu d'un point de vue
constitutionnel donc il y a eu des
décisions de prises sur les retraites
notamment on peut pas avoir purgé des
régimes de retraite mais on a découvert
aussi que par exemple des élus qui avait
une petite retraite Ircantec de quelques
euros par an se retrouvaient dans des
incapacités donc on a eu à gérer ça
qu'elle a été la difficulté je vais vous
le dire aussi il y a une difficulté de
timing parce que entre le moment où le
ministre de l'Agriculture pas celui-là
son prédécesseur avait arrêté les
décisions dans le cadre du CSO et le
moment où les applications les décrets
sont sorties on a été relativement
coincé on s'est retrouvé avec de très
nombreux aquiculteurs qui nous ont dit
que dans le cadre de la négociation de
l'actif tel qu'il avait été menée on se
retrouvait dans des incapacités à
pouvoir bouger et l'objectif c'était pas
de sortir des gens comme ça on a
notamment eu des problèmes avec des gens
qui étaient en société en participation
vous savez des gens qui ont des
assolements en commun qui se mettent à
plusieurs ça arrive dans certains
territoires on a eu des gens qui étaient
salariés de leur structure vous savez ça
peut arriver aussi notamment en
viticulture dans les départements
viticoles je pense à la Gironde mais à
d'autres départements il y a beaucoup de
viticulteurs qui font qui agissent qui
prennent des décisions mais qui sont
salariés d'une structure dans lequel
parfois la famille porte le capital donc
voilà donc là on a demandé au ministère
de pouvoir essayer de baisser le curseur
de telle sorte que les gens et le temps
de s'adapter pour la première
déclaration dont le terme était hier en
revanche et pour réaffirmer que la FNSEA
a une vision nous continuons à
travailler à cette définition de l'actif
non pas pour exclure mais c'est là où je
vais être précis mais pour garantir que
le capital agricole contient sera demain
essentiellement un capital patrimonial
et non pas un capital de fonds de
pension qui n'est pas le modèle agricole
à ce stade alors je le dis aussi on aura
toujours besoin d'accompagnement
bancaire on a besoin d'un banquier on a
besoin d'un financeur mais l'agriculture
française en tous les cas pour ce qui
est de la fin du soir on veut qu'elle
continue à être une agriculture
patrimoniale après tout le monde n'a pas
le même patrimoine mais c'est
essentiellement ça et on a toujours été
extrêmement vigilant à l'apport de
capitaux notamment de capitaux étrangers
mais deux capitaux d'une manière
générale qui seraient demain des fonds
de pension c'est une des raisons
d'ailleurs pour lesquelles on a encore
un foncier puisque ça va me faire la
transition avec votre question sur le
foncier on a un foncier relativement peu
cher en France au regard de ce qui se
passe en Belgique au Pays-Bas même en
Allemagne dans certains coins et ça
c'est aussi le prix de la politique
d'encadrement à quel on tient
à la condition sinequanone que ça ne
réduise pas la capacité de production en
tous les cas pas significativement la
capacité de production dit autrement
aujourd'hui on a vu naître beaucoup de
projets dans lequel on avait un peu de
projet agricoles que je qualifie
d'exotique ou de peu crédibles et les
projets qu'on commence à voir arriver
sont beaucoup plus robustes pour
permettre aux agriculteurs de continuer
à produire soit de l'élevage soit en
viticulture avec des panneaux des
ombriers enfin des choses un peu
technique qui permettent d'avancer et y
compris maintenant aux grandes cultures
avec des panneaux qui peuvent permettre
aux engins de passer sur l'aspect
opportunité et esprit de levier
financier de de la production d'énergie
versus la production agricole nous on
est très favorable à des projets les
plus collectifs possibles parce que
c'est aussi la garantie qu'on aura
demain de pouvoir
assurer une forme de rentabilité des
projets dans lequel le monde agricole
aura sa part c'est la discussion que
nous avons en ce moment avec les
énergéticien c'est de dire que dans le
cadre de l'intérêt de la nation
développer des énergies renouvelables
nous ne sommes pas ossiles simplement on
veut pas juste être la variable
d'ajustement donc nous on dit quels sont
les types de projets quelle valeur crée
le projet et comment on répartit la
valeur pardonnez-moi la comparaison mais
c'était exactement la même discussion
qu'avec la grande distribution dire que
on comprend qu'il y a besoin de
développer on comprend qu'il y a un
certain nombre d'acteurs souvent des
très gros acteurs très bien organisés
nous ce qu'on dit c'est que dit on va
vous donner un peu plus que ce qu'est le
fermage pour le propriétaire ou quelques
compensations pour l'exploitant ça n'est
pas suffisant et pourquoi on veut le
faire de collectivement parce qu'on sait
que si on le fait pas collectivement on
va avoir des tensions fortes sur le
terrain qui ne seront pas durables et
c'est les lieux locales qui vous parle
si on veut que les projets sortent vite
que ils fassent l'objet d'une
concertation entre les élus locaux comme
idée d'agglomération comité de communes
le monde agricole sur l'accès aux
fonciers l'alignement des CD pennaf
toutes les organisations on a intérêt
que on ne part pas sur trois ou quatre
ans de triple administratif d'appel
voilà on a besoin un moment d'une forme
de concertation équilibrée donc je ne
crains pas ça pour peu que on continue à
produire et qu'on ne détruise pas de
valeur ajoutée on veut le faire
collectivement et on veut protéger pour
répondre là aussi très précisément
puisque visiblement la dernière fois
c'était ça l'était pas sur le statut du
fermage on veut continuer à ce qu'on
puisse bénéficier du statut du fermage
on est en train de regarder parce
qu'effectivement juridiquement il
pourrait y avoir tel que son construit
aujourd'hui les mots quelques quelques
problématiques alors je suis pas assez à
ce stade avancé pour pouvoir vous le
dire mais on est en train de regarder et
nous on continuera à défendre le statut
du fermage évidemment et j'ajoute pour
aller jusqu'au bout à la restitution des
terres au terme parce que personne n'en
parle aujourd'hui on dit on va
construire mais
l'agriculteur est là dans le temps long
et donc nous ça nous intéresse de savoir
ce que deviennent les terres au terme
des projets et notamment les quantités
nécessaires de structure si c'est du
démontage ça va si c'est du béton c'est
un autre sujet donc on a besoin de
regarder tout ça voilà
madame la sénatrice donc sur les sujets
d'eau et de sécheresse j'ai essayé de
répondre évidemment il y a le sujet du
partage de la ressource je lis aussi
parce que l'agriculture a beaucoup été
montré du doigt et encore une fois elle
est un acteur de premier plan mais vous
savez aussi que sur les réseaux
d'adduction d'eau on a quelques sujets
quand même de réseau d'efficacité du
réseau voilà donc nous on souhaite aussi
qu'on puisse parler de l'ensemble de la
problématique mais en tous les cas on
est on est prêt votre département porte
un certain nombre de réserves je pense
au lac du Der voilà qui permet je le dis
quand même ici au Parisien de bénéficier
d'un flux d'eau permanent y compris
l'été alors que c'était pas complètement
acquis et donc c'était finalement pas si
mal que la planification golienne permet
de faire ça j'aurais pu en parler pour
Serre-Ponçon si on parlait de la nuance
et d'autres du canal de la NES dans le
Gers enfin voilà tous les travaux
hydrauliques qui permettent aujourd'hui
à une agriculture équilibrée de vivre
sont aussi le fruit de choix politique
qui ont permis d'avoir une vision de
long terme si je puis dire
sur la réutilisation des eaux usées la
France est très en deçà de la main donc
je pense qu'on les on peut aller
beaucoup plus loin alors il se trouve
que j'ai eu la chance d'aller récemment
en Israël qui est ce pays très en point
pour des raisons de géopolitique que
chacun comprend
et qui obtient des résultats très très
satisfaisant avec ce qu'ils appellent
des eaux somatres y compris pour
produire des fruits dans le négaie sous
45 degrés donc il se fait des choses
enfin c'est possible quelle est la
volonté politique et quel est le niveau
d'investissement je vous renverrai bien
la balle mais en tous les cas
mais en tous les cas mais
en tous les cas Nono je parlais
évidemment du territoire national je
vais vous sentez monsieur le sénateur
voilà donc en tous les cas nous on est
très parti prenante et sur la
décennalisation ça pourrait être une
opportunité mais les coûts sont
aujourd'hui assez prohibitifs on sait
que ça fonctionne Israël le fait aussi
voilà mais oui le Maroc aussi va tous
les pays donc probablement cela
devrait-il faire l'objet d'une
discussion voilà je pense notamment à la
partie septentrionale de notre de pardon
méridionale de notre pays parce que ce
que ce que j'ai vu notamment dans les PO
n'hésitera probablement qu'on ait des
réponses un peu plus adaptées il faut
trouver aussi l'équilibre économique
parce qu'évidemment derrière quel est le
coût d'accès à l'eau quelles sont les
conditions et puis on aura un petit
sujet quand même de de bactériologie on
a aujourd'hui on a aujourd'hui des des
essais qui sont pas complètement
concluants l'objectif ultime étant
évidemment de garantir aux consommateurs
la plus totale innocuité
sur ces sujets là je voudrais dire aussi
parce que quand on parle beaucoup d'eau
on dit on parle produit phytosanitaire
vous le savez certainement mais on
retrouve tout dans l'eau aujourd'hui
toutes les matières actives y compris
celles qui ne sont pas agricoles et pour
ceux qui suivent ces sujets on a des
petits sujets autour de l'oestrogène en
ce moment qui font débat dans le
traitement de l'eau voilà je le dis
l'agriculture évidemment une
responsabilité et pas question de se
dégager mais c'est une vision un peu
globale qu'il faut avoir sur les sujets
de surtransposition
que vous dire l'arlésienne notre pays à
cette capacité à produire
de la norme des règles dans des
proportions qui montrent l'efficacité
bon voilà ça n'est plus tenable je pense
pour en discuter régulièrement avec
d'autres corps intermédiaires en dehors
du monde agricole que c'est devenu un
des sujets central de la capacité à
entreprendre et ça n'est pas je crois
pas qu'il faille le vivre comme espèce
de
volonté de Total libéralisme pas du tout
on a besoin de règles on a besoin
d'encadrement et je veux le dire aussi
devant vous l'agriculture a besoin de
régulation
en revanche
le nombre de surtranspositions
sur tout un tas de sujets
l'afflux administratif rend même notre
propre administration décentralisée je
pense notamment à nos directions
départementales des territoires parfois
dans des dans des schizophrénies
difficiles à comprendre pour
l'agriculteur qui interpelle voilà donc
je vais vous donner un cas que j'ai vécu
en Côte-d'Or où j'étais vendredi où nous
avons un sujet de tuberculose bovine et
où les services de l'État entre l'Office
français de la biodiversité d'un côté et
la DGL de l'autre se renvoient la balle
pour savoir comment on peut oui ou non
nourrir les animaux aux champs voilà bon
et les agriculteurs disent nous on veut
bien mais dites nous et la plaisanterie
dure depuis plus de 10 ans voilà et ça
rend les gens absolument dingues de ne
pas être en capacité de comprendre
comment on peut faire donc voilà ça
c'est des exemples très concrets je
pourrais vous en citer bien d'autres
donc sur la surtransposition
effectivement si on pouvait au moins
coller à la vision globale et faire en
sorte que si des décisions se prennent
elles se prennent pour tout le monde ça
nous aiderait grandement en grandement
enfin vous parliez d'enseignement
agricole j'en ai dit un mot c'est une
bonne chose je retiens surtout ce que
vous avez dit sur la détresse je
voudrais vous donner un chiffre qui date
de ce matin
qui m'a été fourni par le président
national de la mutualité sociale
agricole et qui constate une envolée du
nombre d'appels dans les standards de la
MSA depuis la parution du rapport de la
Cour des comptes
je vous le dis parce que il faut prendre
mais ce sujet est un sujet grave je
voilà
une envolée des appels alors pas tout de
nature dramatique et tant mieux mais
enfin puisque la MSA a mis en place ce
type de d'accompagnement et c'est une
bonne chose puisque
un ancien parlementaire monsieur damezin
a repris le sujet du mal-être en
agriculture voilà vous aviez travaillé
absolument voilà que j'ai vu récemment
je considère que il faut aussi qu'on
veille à faire en sorte que les gens
comprennent que ce qu'ils font ont du
sens je crois que c'est vrai dans toutes
les professions et on a ça régulièrement
besoin de le faire en agriculture
très bien merci pour ces premières
réponses je voudrais d'abord réparer un
oubli regrettable et je voudrais saluer
monsieur Clément Forex qui est le
directeur général de la FNSEA voilà que
je n'avais pas accueilli voilà ainsi que
Xavier Jamet que nous connaissons un peu
dans cette maison et que nous remercions
d'être là également je voudrais aussi
excuser puisque vous avez cité le
rapport de Françoise Ferrat et celui de
notre collègue Henri Cabanel pour
excuser Henri qui a un petit problème de
suite dans son accident de tracteur
comme quoi vous voyez on a les mêmes
sujets voilà partout voilà je vais
laisser la parole à mes collègues
maintenant je vous laisse deux minutes
mes chers collègues parce que sinon le
on va on va trop dépasser Jean-Marc
Boyer
oui merci madame la présidente monsieur
le Président je voudrais vous remercier
de ce discours et de ses objectifs
réconfortants que vous avez donné ce
matin ça remet beaucoup et pas mal
d'optimisme dans nos dans nos propos
parce que dans le climat de contraintes
et anxiogène que l'on vit actuellement
sur les chaînes d'information continue
et à travers le rapport de l'accord des
comptes mais j'y reviendrai tout à
l'heure j'ai deux questions concernant
le zan en particulier la loi qui a été
votée ici au Sénat qui ont des spare
sera voté l'Assemblée nationale bientôt
prévoit une garantie rurale d'un hectare
par commune j'aimerais savoir ce que
vous en pensez et si vous pensez aussi
qu'il est nécessaire de sortir les
bâtiments agricoles de la surface des
ânes deuxième question
concernant le rapport de la Chambre
régionale des comptes qui préconise une
baisse du nombre de bovins en France
alors que en France on a 17 millions de
bovins sur 17 milliards qu'il y a sur la
c'est à dire 1% de l'ensemble des bovins
qui a sur l'ensemble de la planète et
qui correspond à 1% du libération de CO2
alors est-ce qu'aujourd'hui on est
obligé de dire qu'il faut que le
français mange pas plus de 500 g de
viande par semaine parce que sinon il
détruit la planète que pensez-vous de
ces injonctions et ces mots d'ordre
d'hyperticide qui pour nous enseigne
tous les jours troisième question les
gens témoin madame la Présidente vous
avez parlé de l'enseignement agricoles
alors on a eu on avait un rapport qui
avait été produit concernant l'ancienne
agricole il y a deux ans et seulement on
s'apaisait aujourd'hui que des élèves
d'origine de
agricoles sont à peu près de 20%
actuellement il y en a 80% qui ne sont
plus d'origine agricole donc ils n'ont
pas vraiment de projet de l'installation
en agriculture et dont les critères
pédagogiques aujourd'hui ne
correspondent pas forcément à ce qu'on
voudrait avoir en termes de en terme de
projet donc quelle piste pouvez-vous
préconiser pour qu'on ait effectivement
demain des agricules des jeunes qui
s'orientent beaucoup plus sur
l'enseignement agricole et en
particulier vers les filières bovins et
le élevage d'été etc merci beaucoup
Jean-Marc
le 14
Bernard buis ensuite Dominique Estrosi
ça sonne merci présidente merci monsieur
le Président pour vos propos clairs et
affirmés donc dans le cadre du plan de
la loi d'orientation et d'avenir
Agricole vous proposez de défendre la
spécificité de l'enseignement agricole
dans le cas de la réforme du lycée
professionnel quel est votre position
sur la réforme du lycisme professionnel
et qu'entendez-vous plus précisément par
défendre la spécificité de
l'anciennement Agricole vous estimez
qu'il est nécessaire d'adapter la
réglementation de sorte que les jeunes
de moins de 18 ans puissent s'effectuer
davantage de stage de manipulation et de
gestes techniques sur les exploitations
agricoles la réglementation relative à
la santé à la sécurité au travail des
travailleurs mineurs et très exigeantes
vous considérez qu'elle pourrait être
assouplie afin de permettre aux jeunes
de pouvoir se confronter davantage aux
contraintes des métiers agricoles avec
l'objectif que leur période d'alternance
et de stage en entreprise et un sens
comment souhaitez-vous concrètement
adapter la réglementation en question
avez-vous des exemples concrets en
matière d'assouplissement de la
réglementation et enfin j'ai été alerté
par Madame Sandrine Rousset président de
la dsea de la Drôme sur le projet de
directive sur les émissions
industrielles quelle est la position de
la FNSEA sur ce sujet monsieur le
Président avez-vous échangé sur ce sujet
avec les ministères concernés
et puis bien sûr vous êtes le bienvenue
dans la Drôme peut-être à l'occasion du
salon tech en bio en septembre
c'est dégoûtant parce qu'il nous invite
pas nous donc merci merci beaucoup
Bernard
ah voilà Dominique Estrosi ça sonne
ensuite Martin Berthet merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Président à mon
tour de ma société à mes collègues pour
la clarté la précision et l'engagement
de vos propos trois rapides questions
sur trois thématiques d'abord celle de
la prédation je vais pas vous dire
combien aujourd'hui cette prédation du
loup cause des dommages considérables à
l'élevage combien nos éleveurs
aujourd'hui sont en détresse dans tous
les territoires puisque l'espèce
prolifère est aujourd'hui présente dans
plus de 52 départements et bien
évidemment elle cause d'importants
dommages à travers les fortes attaques
et les nombreuses victimes est-ce que
donc on est dans une phase cruciale
puisque donc on va rentrer dans le
nouveau plan national lou est-ce que
vous vous êtes donc vous échangez avec
le gouvernement au sujet de la prédation
plus généralement et aussi de la
négociation du prochain plan national
loup parce que force de reconnaître que
le Parlement est pour le moins
complètement écarté de cette négociation
donc on a ainsi un groupe qui travaille
sur le sujet du loup mais néanmoins
c'est extrêmement difficile de pouvoir
se faire entendre et faire porter un
certain nombre de messages je voudrais
revenir rapidement sur la question de la
sécheresse dans mon département vous
avez fait référence de nombreuses
communes font aujourd'hui l'objet d'un
arrêté préfectoral de sécheresse qui
limite fortement la consommation d'eau
il y a un certain nombre de
gestionnaires de lots qui considèrent
que le compteur d'eau intelligent a
vraiment un rôle d'alerteur important
que pensez-vous de la généralisation des
compteurs d'eau intelligents et qui
pourraient s'appliquer à l'ensemble des
compteurs qu'ils soient agricoles ou non
et aujourd'hui je sais que dans mon
département la FDSEA souhaiterait qu'il
puisse y avoir des compteurs séparés
parce que vous n'ignorez pas qu'il y a
dans notre département de nombreuses
résidences voilà qui appartiennent à des
gens qui sont extrêmement riches
mieux n'économise en rien l'eau que ce
soit pour arroser leur pelouse ou pour
remplir leur piscine mais comme on a
aussi l'obligation de ne pas couper
l'eau puisque c'est un bien commun je
sais que la fds ea06 souhaiterait qu'il
puisse y avoir mais ça ça remonte à
pouvoir revenir sur la loi Brotte qui
puisse y avoir des compteurs qui soient
bien séparés de façon à ce qu'on puisse
peut-être couper certains compteurs mais
pas d'autres et enfin dernière question
sur votre approche sur les paiements
pour service environnementaux en
agriculture en 2019 la FNSEA est
présentée épither un programme
d'accompagnement des agriculteurs et des
acteurs privés au public souhaitant
signer ces contrats quel est le bilan
aujourd'hui et comment vous voyez les
choses évoluer potentiellement
merci Dominique la parole est à Martine
Berthet ensuite joël Labbé merci madame
la Présidente alors deux points le
premier Martine Berthet pardon sénatrice
de la Savoie le premier pour appuyer ce
que vient de dire ma collègue Dominique
Estrosi ça sonne sur le sujet du loup et
des messages reçus
tous les jours quasiment d'agriculteurs
d'éleveurs qui sont au désespoir qui
nous disent qu'il casse ce problème du
loup s'ajoute le problème de lentille
élevage et pour eux c'est vraiment une
catastrophe ils ont l'impression que
leur métier est détruit y compris pour
leurs enfants et ne voient plus de
solutions donc voilà quelles actions
comptez-vous mener dans ce cadre-là
quelle mesure également auprès des
collégiens pour l'attractivité de tous
les métiers de l'agriculture je me fais
le relais ici de nos
arboriculteurs pardon producteurs donc
de fruits qui sont très nombreux en
Savoie mais
ne trouve personne pour travailler à
leur côté et qui surtout s'inquiète
énormément pour la relève donc c'est une
sujet assez désespérant pour eux et qui
s'ajoute à toutes les contraintes qu'il
subissent actuellement pour mettre en
œuvre leurs production merci merci
beaucoup
Joël Labé ensuite Anne Catherine Loisier
merci madame la Présidente une question
concernant la viande d'invitrome
monsieur le président lors d'une
audition au Sénat dans le cadre de la
mission d'information sur le
développement de la viande d'une vitro
le représentant de la FNSEA déclaré que
votre syndicat n'était pas fermé à la
viande d'invitro précisant que les
femmes françaises étant trop petites
pour être compétitive et de ce fait
satisfaire une demande alimentaire bon
marché donc ce serait une solution
d'avenir donc c'est pas ce que nous
partageons j'aurais souhaité votre point
de vue là dessus d'autre part je
voudrais dire monsieur le Président
Madame la Présidente que je trouve très
intéressant de que vous veniez vous nous
présenter vos positions par rapport à
l'agriculture l'agriculture est
plurielle vous l'avez dit aussi tout à
l'heure et je pense qu'il serait
intéressant madame la Présidente chers
collègues que nous recevions également
en audition les représentants des autres
syndicats je vous remercie très bien
merci
[Musique]
pardon ensuite Daniel Gremillet merci
Madame présidente merci monsieur le
Président surtout de tracer des
perspectives et les objectifs et je
pense qu'effectivement on a besoin que
ce soit les agriculteurs ou même
parlementaires de de savoir un petit peu
mieux où on va alors en matière de
perspective vous avez pas beaucoup parlé
de la politique agricole donc que
pensez-vous aujourd'hui justement des
objectifs du Green Deal puisqu'on sait
que enfin tout faux qu'on était dans une
stratégie de diminution de la production
donc
comment comment doit-on aujourd'hui
peut-être revoir ses objectifs pour
qu'il réponde mieux à tous les enjeux
que vous avez largement évoqués vous
avez parlé de la fin du latéralisme mais
en l'occurrence dans le monde agricole
c'est pas la fin du multilatéralisme et
on a encore un certain nombre de de
points à acter deux petites questions
rapides madame la précédente sur le
développement des EnR en Côte-d'Or
le projet de loi qui a été validée pose
un certain nombre cette question par
exemple
s'agissant de la médiatisation comment
on peut faire en sorte que des petites
unités sur des territoires où il y a un
potentiel sur des zones intermédiaires à
faible potentiel ne soit pas écartés de
ces dispositifs et je crois qu'il y a un
certain nombre de modalités tant dans la
grève voltaïsme que sur la méthanisation
qui écarte en fait un certain les
petites unités et qui vont un peu à
l'encontre finalement du modèle qu'on
souhaite développer de diversification
mais assis sur une production locale et
puis deuxième dernière question sur
egalim on a beaucoup parlé du revenu des
agriculteurs le revenu c'est pas
seulement les prises sont aussi les
aides et les charges voilà donc comment
effectivement diminuer les charges mais
à ce stade vous m'aviez laissé entendre
il y a quelques jours que vous vous
aviez déjà quelques éléments de de bilan
d'étape je dirais sur la
contractualisation sur la
non-négociabilité des matières premières
agricoles donc quels sont ces éléments
un peu de l'évaluation des PACS d'impact
des galimes sachant que la première
année on avait effectivement
constaté une augmentation d'à peu près
trois et demi je crois pour cent de des
tarifs donc où en sommes-nous à ce stade
merci merci Anne-Catherine Daniel
Gremillet ensuite amalgaquer
oui merci Madame la présente merci
Arnaud pour la qualité de ton
intervention j'aurai une première
question
c'est le problème de la relation de la
consommation
alimentaire par rapport à nos
concitoyens
aujourd'hui on parle du chèque
alimentaire on parle du parnéatif et
inflation des tas de collectivités
prennent des mesures parce que la
population n'est plus en capacité de se
nourrir on imagine aussi pour les
étudiants et pourtant en 80
un tiers du revenu de ménage allait pour
l'alimentation et la part des jardins
familiaux était très importante
aujourd'hui en 2023 c'est à peine 16%.
donc il y a une première question
effectivement comment on marcher sur la
tête et aujourd'hui que le contribuable
en soit conduit à aller alimenter
ça coûte et on est complètement à
l'envers par rapport à la reconnaissance
du métier de l'agriculteur
deuxième point c'est la lame de fond sur
l'élevage trop c'est trop et
effectivement je vais plus loin que ce
que tu as évoqué sur l'alerte de la MSA
le rapport de la Cour des comptes c'est
c'est vraiment ce qui va ce qui fait
déborder le vase et arrive demain le
dossier bien-être animal ne l'oublions
pas qui va coûter et ça va faire ce qui
s'est passé sur les productions 10 tours
seul en France et pourquoi je parle de
lames de fond j'ai la responsabilité du
dossier énergétique ça me fait penser au
nucléaire à force de dire qu'on en veut
plus que ces mauvais etc et bien
effectivement aujourd'hui le rapport de
la Cour des comptes tu sais que j'ai
encore quelques petites responsabilités
dans l'alimentaire je suis choqué
d'entendre des cadres d'entreprises
agroalimentaires qui me disent mais
attends Daniel
moi je reste plus dans un pays je vais
aller ailleurs dans un pays qui croit
encore à la transformation des produits
de l'élevage donc il y a un souci
terrible qui frappe les éleveurs mais
qui frappe aussi tout l'environnement de
la valorisation alimentaire derrière sur
leur nouvellement des générations qui
vont être bref renouvellement des
générations
il faut rentrer dans des contrats plus
longs depuis l'âge entre un jeune qui
arrive qui est pas forcément issu du
milieu agricole et un départ et c'est
pas en trois ans il faut quelque chose
de plus lourd plus offensif et dernier
point sur dossier égalim
et dossiers égalim
on a toujours dit que le dossier mégalim
ne pouvait fonctionner en France que
lorsqu'on était dans la déflation
n'oubliez pas les chiffres 2022 le prix
du lait était à 470 euros les 1000
litres en France il est monté à 580 600
dans d'autres pays on est ils avant
dernier de la classe en France par
rapport à l'Europe aujourd'hui le prix
baisse au niveau des autres pays et
c'est seulement aujourd'hui que le
système égalime peut apporter des
revenus à l'éleveur français et pourtant
c'est en France aujourd'hui ou même le
ministre des conneries l'économie
demande de renégocier les prix j'ai pas
le temps mais j'aurais un exemple
cuisant je le ferai dans le cadre du
rapport avec Anne-Catherine sur le suivi
Gallim mais il fait des chiffres très
intéressant sur à qui est allé la valeur
par rapport au prix payé par le
consommateur
merci Daniel heureusement Anne-Catherine
t'avais laissé un peu de temps Amel
gacquet ensuite Daniel salmon monsieur
le Président tout d'abord je vais
commencer par vous dire je me réjouis de
certaines de vos positions très claires
notamment celles sur l'usage des phytos
des produits phytos donc oui à une
réduction de leur usage mais non à des
interdictions sèches qui nous mettent
vraiment dans des impasses et j'ai envie
de dire dans notre beau département dans
mon beau département du Pas-de-Calais
nous en avons fait les frères récemment
notamment encore avec la culture
betteravière qui aujourd'hui est encore
dans une situation très compliquée deux
questions rapides la première celle qui
porte sur la situation de la filière de
la pomme de terre affectée par la
sécheresse de 2022 affecté aussi par la
hausse des coûts de l'énergie en 2022 le
rendement national a baissé de 12% par
rapport à 2021
la récolte la plus faible depuis ses 20
dernières années donc un sujet essentiel
pour nous dans la région de France
puisque nous concentrons aujourd'hui
deux tiers de la production nationale au
sein de notre région donc c'est un vrai
sujet et face à l'été qui se profile
j'avais envie de vous entendre
d'entendre votre vision parce que vous
avez déjà évoqué le sujet de l'eau mais
il y a des questions d'urgence
aujourd'hui que peut-on attendre que
pouvez-vous dire en tout cas que
pourrons-nous attendre ensemble du
gouvernement sur cette question
autre et dernière question vous avez
évoqué à plusieurs reprises nous avons
évoqué la souveraineté alimentaire bien
sûr l'enjeu hyper important que nous
partageons puisque nous l'évoquons ici
très très régulièrement nous savons que
notre agriculture est dépendante de
nombreux intrants la production agricole
française dépend entre 40 et 50% d'un an
importé directement ou indirectement
avec mes collègues donc Sophie prima et
Franck motoget nous avons co-écrit un
rapport dans lequel nous recommandons
pardons d'élaborer un plan de résilience
de la chaîne alimentaire pour mieux
prévenir qui inclut un meilleur suivi de
stock stratégique pour les denrées
agricoles j'en termine là-dessus
l'Allemagne a adopté en 2017 une loi sur
la fourniture de denrées alimentaires de
base en cas de crise d'approvisionnement
qui donne donc autorité au gouvernement
pour déclarer une crise de la
provisionnement et prendre les mesures
nécessaires
en amont y compris en amont donc
notamment la constitution de stocks de
denrées sont celles et l'obligation
d'informations sur sur ces stocks que
pensez-vous de cette recommandation
est-ce que nous aurions intérêt à aller
dans ce sens je vais terminer par vous
dire également vous êtes le bienvenu
dans 62
ça devient merci merci beaucoup Amel
Daniel salmon suite Christian sarrazzi
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
Président je suis quelque peu inquiet
parce que vous avez parlé de d'assurer
la continuité or si je regarde le bilan
de ces dernières décennies il n'est pas
franchement bon nous avons plus 100000
actifs agricoles en l'espace de 10 ans
nous avons perdu 80% de la masse des
insectes et et l'effondrement des
oiseaux c'est 60% des oiseaux des champs
il y a une étude qui vient de sortir
là-dessus et les pesticides sont pointés
très clairement au niveau de l'Europe
c'est pas simplement une histoire de
patrimoine et d'histoire c'est aussi une
question de résilience car vous le savez
la biodiversité est essentielle à la
résilience donc voilà est-ce que c'est
continuité c'est dans ce sens là ce qui
ce qui serait très inquiétant autre
chose vous avez parlé du foncier
agricole effectivement nous avons besoin
de préserver ce foncier par contre un
jeune sur deux qui se destine à
l'agriculture
souhaite s'installer en agriculture
biologique à votre avis comment
devons-nous faire pour accompagner ce
mouvement qui me semble qui me semble
crucial dernière chose effectivement
aujourd'hui on met beaucoup sur la
sellette des études celle de parfois de
landeces là on parlait de la Cour des
comptes on parle également de l'inrae
parfois quels sont vos relations avec
ces organismes merci
Daniel Christian Redon sarrazzi ensuite
Denis boide
merci
monsieur le Président donc pour vos
propos vous avez évoqué le foncier ça a
été évoqué aussi par plusieurs de mes
collègues on le sait c'est central pour
le renouvellement des générations et le
maintien d'une activité agricole quel
que soit le type de territoire
d'ailleurs or dans les zones que l'on
qualifie d'intermédiaire et en
particulier d'élevage où le revenu à
l'hectare est faible et ou par
conséquent les installations sont en
chute libre et encore plus dans ces
zones qu'ailleurs les cédants qui sont
souvent des marchés par les opérateurs
d'énergie aux pratiques commerciales que
l'on peut qualifier d'agressive se
laisse parfois séduire et soustrait
ainsi des hectares à l'activité agricole
je voudrais savoir quelle est la
position de la FNSEA sur ce sujet même
si vous en avez un peu évoqué mais plus
précisément sur les sécrétions
d'activités et notamment soyons
favorables à ce que des contraintes sur
le devenir du foncier agricole s'impose
aux propriétaires qui cessent leur
activité et qui dans certains cas sont
prêts à céder aux sirènes je dirais des
des opérateurs d'énergie photovoltaïques
ou ou bien
c'est la Haute Vienne merci beaucoup
Christian Denis de bois denis-boite
pardon ensuite Fabien gay merci madame
la Présidente Monsieur le Président vous
avez déclaré dans un quotidien il y a un
mois maintenant que sur 100 euros
dépensés pour l'alimentation
6,90 € à l'agriculture pouvez nous
expliquer en quelques mots ou passer la
différence
merci la concision de la question mais
elle est directe et claire
un gay ensuite Olivier Rickman qui
apportera des précisions monsieur le
président
sur beaucoup de questions un dialogue
démocratique et républicain j'ai des
points d'accord des points des accords
c'est normal je pense que la gestion de
l'eau par exemple ça devrait nous animer
beaucoup plus que que ça et je vois même
que Dominique maintenant parle de bien
commun non mais en tout cas c'est une
véritable question je pense que personne
a la solution mais moi je fais la
différence entre le pompage la retenue
mais il y aura une question parce que je
pense qu'on est plus il y a 50 ans et
que ça va nous poser des questions pour
l'agriculture pour la biodiversité pour
l'énergie et on va on va avoir des
problèmes mais passons je vous inviterai
dans mon département un beau département
agricole aussi
dans le 93 mais on a on a des terres
agricoles à trembler à Coubron on fait
l'apiculture du maréchal
des vignobles devraient pas le dire ici
mais il est pas très bon il était
meilleur dans ma région d'origine
directe moi c'est sur les traités de
libre-échange parce que si on trouvait
des points d'accord aujourd'hui
je suis un farouche opposant à ces
questions non pas que je ne pense pas
qu'il faille commercer mais je pense que
ce qui rentre ici
ne peut pas être au moins 10 ans social
et environnemental et interdire de faire
de produire ici et l'autoriser
évidemment à l'étranger donc la question
quel est votre position sur les traités
de libre-échange et sur une question
particulière parce que c'est l'ancien
ministre de Normandie qui avait commencé
ça sur les clauses miroir
qu'en pensez-vous
moi je pense évidemment ça serait très
bien mais
permettez-moi de donner une opinion je
pense que c'est fait pour nous faire
avaler la question des traités de
libre-échange parce que si demain il y a
des clauses miroir bon bah il y a plus
de traiter de libre-échange c'est ça la
question parce que si on autorise plus
ce qui est produit au moins de 10 ans
social et environnementale c'est autre
chose qu'un traité libre-échange c'est
du commerce équitable une nouvelle
coopération ce que moi je pense mais bon
voilà je voulais en tout cas votre
position sur cette question je vous
remercie merci beaucoup Fabien
et ensuite pierre Cuypers oui merci
madame la Présidente merci monsieur le
Président je vous poserai pas de
question particulièrement je veux pas
rajouter du débat au débat Olivier
Rickman sénateur de la Haute-Saône
j'aurais pu vous poser un certain nombre
de questions j'étais rapporteur de son
pastou et en ce moment je fais un
rapport sur la simplification des normes
et des règles donc voyez qu'il y avait
matière mais quand vous viendrez dans le
70 on a l'occasion d'en parler je
voulais rectifier et apporter une
précision par rapport à la question de
notre collègue
joël Labbé parce que j'étais le
rapporteur avec Henri Cabanel sur le
rapport sur les aliments cellulaires ce
qu'on appelle le virement la viande in
vitro et c'est moi qui ai fait
l'audition j'ai peut-être fait une
erreur parce que j'ai fait l'audition
simultanée des trois représentants
principaux des syndicats agricoles
Confédération coordination et FNSEA et
immédiatement derrière le représentant
pour pas le citer de la Confédération a
fait un communiqué de presse déformant
complètement les propos mesure
présentant de la FNSEA disant que la
FNSEA soutenait acté la future
production d'aliments cellulaire etc
alors c'est absolument pas le cas j'en
suis témoin j'étais là donc voilà faut
pas tout déformer jamais leur présentant
de la FNSEA n'a soutenu par quelques
moyens que ce soit il a la même position
que nous là-dessus dans le sens où
politiquement et en tant que
représentant du monde agricole ne peut
pas défendre ce genre d'industrie
maintenant on a je pense également le
rapport traduisait cette chose là c'est
que la décision de mise sur le marché
n'étant pas une décision nationale mais
européenne si toutefois un jour ça
venait arriver
la présentatrice disait que il faudra
que l'agriculture fasse en sorte elle
défenseur des agriculteurs façon en
sorte qu'il adapter voilà c'était juste
ça ça vous exonère d'une réponse en même
temps
mais après le 16e marnais pierre Cupper
ce qui va clôturer cette séance de
questions
qui va t'inviter
force monsieur le Président de toutes
les invitations qui vous sont faites je
vous invite à rester
néanmoins souvent dans le département de
cinéma voilà vous avez abordé tout à
l'heure la souveraineté alimentaire et
très peu de la souveraineté énergétique
pour autant l'agriculture apporte
tellement de solutions et pour autant et
en contradiction il y a toujours cette
opposition entre les usages alimentaires
et non alimentaires quelle est la
position de la FNSEA que je connais mais
merci de le dire
très bien merci monsieur le Président
vous avez fort à faire il y a des
thématiques récurrentes le temps qu'il
est nécessaire qui nous est nécessaire
mais je vais essayer d'être concis je
vais essayer d'être concis
première question du sénateur Boyer
voilà sur Lausanne donc effectivement on
a eu on a eu une position de l'effet des
soirs nous sommes favorables alors ça a
été un débat parce que voilà vous savez
dès qu'on parle du foncier les fenêtre
une forme de crispation bon on a on a
fait en sorte de faire comprendre que il
y avait besoin de développement et
l'idée que on puisse avoir un hectare
alors dans les communes rurales qu'on
soit précis serait une position
d'équilibre que qui nous conviendrait et
pour répondre là aussi à votre question
pour les bâtiments agricoles on serait
pas dansé surfaces là et je voudrais
précis dans les bâtiments agricoles
c'est non seulement les bâtiments
agricoles mais c'est aussi ceux qui
relève de la méthanisation agricole là
aussi je le dis puisque dans les
discussions qu'on a avec le gouvernement
il y a l'idée de développer la
méthanisation sous des formes à discuter
mais en tous les cas voilà et que ça
fera la liaison après avec d'autres
questions que la méthanisation agricole
nécessite une consommation foncier pas
très importante que nous on préférait
regrouper les projets
à l'échelle locale pour éviter la
multiplication de la consommation de
fonciers mais qu'évidemment si
l'objectif dont parle le gouvernement
qui serait de à peu près 1000 unités
agricoles aujourd'hui à
entre 5 et 10 000 je sais pas quelle
sera le chiffre encore une fois je
laisse les gens non c'est la compétence
le faire on aura évidemment des
consommations de foncil haddock et ça
peut pas rentrer dans sa voilà donc ok
pour un hectare et
bâtiments agricoles
hors situations
sur la Cour des comptes bah écoutez je
crois que j'ai répondu alors juste pour
vous dire donc d'abord la Cour des
Comptes est une institution indépendante
j'ai constaté que le président le
premier président lui-même était venu
expliquer son rapport ce qui me laisse à
penser que il y avait une forme de gêne
moi je vais vous dire ce qui me gêne
plus profondément c'est que dans la
d'ailleurs le contenu du rapport en
lui-même et quelque chose qui mérite
d'être regardé ce que nous avons
évidemment fait de précision ce qui pose
problème c'est la page 8 de ce rapport
dans lequel il y a deux recommandations
avec un esprit de synthèse c'est
remarquable je dois dire un il faut
réduire le cheptel et deux il faut faire
un plan d'accompagnement à laver à la
sortie de des éleveurs qui sont pas en
situation de de résister bon évidemment
quand vous synthétisez de travail de
cette manière ça rend les choses
compliquées plus largement parce
qu'encore une fois et donc le premier
président de la Cour des comptes
monsieur Moscovici c'est rapproché de la
FNSEA pour nous demander à pouvoir
échanger ce qu'on aurait fait bien
volontiers avant le rapport ce qui nous
ont invité de le faire après évidemment
si on peut se permettre d'être efficace
ce n'est que mieux pour tout le monde et
pour eux d'abord et je suis pas sûr que
par ailleurs ça grandisse vraiment
l'institution vous aurez été que la
FNSEA n'a aucun moment attaqué la Cour
des comptes sur son utilité alors
qu'elle l'a fait sur une idée d'élevage
je voudrais aussi le préciser ici il me
semble que dans le cadre
du débat autour des institutions les
représentants des institutions ne
devraient pas être ceux qui mettent de
l'huile sur le feu
sur
les pistes des filières bovine on y
travaille parce que et je voudrais
essayer d'être équilibré dans mon propos
mais dans ce rapport il y a notamment
comment on continue à créer de la valeur
ajoutée il y a un sujet autour de de
l'engraissement qui est un sujet
intéressant dans lequel nous on va faire
des propositions avec un certain nombre
d'acteurs économiques pour voir comment
on peut tenir ça y compris et pour
répondre à la question de comment on
donne de la perspective aux jeunes qui
veulent s'installer et pardonnez-moi
j'essaie de répondre de manière
synthétique mais il avait été question
de comment on attire les jeunes il faut
savoir que aujourd'hui l'élevage attire
encore des jeunes et probablement plus
que dans d'autres secteurs d'activité
c'était le cas notamment chez vous
monsieur le sénateur dans la Loire
je continue sur les spécificités
agricoles
donc sur les spécifiques agricoles nous
on tient à cette spécificité
pardonnez-moi je cherche le sénateur
buis là pardonnez-moi
on tient cette spécificité d'abord parce
qu'elle est rattachée au ministère de
l'Agriculture et vous savez pour une
partie de l'enseignement ça n'est pas le
cas donc on compte nous on souhaite
pouvoir continuer à garder la main
ensuite parce que on trouve intéressant
d'avoir la spécificité des exploitations
au sein même des lycées d'enseignement
on trouve que c'est intéressant pour les
les élèves de pouvoir bénéficier d'un
aspect pratique directement sur le lycée
et on est convaincu que si on change on
aura probablement un certain nombre de
ces fermes qui qui disparaîtront et puis
on est prêt aussi à on veut travailler
sur les orientations ça nous paraît
important d'être co-constructeur c'est à
dire que à la fois les professionnels
puissent dire qu'elle ambition il porte
pour l'agriculture que ça puisse être
fait de concert avec le corps enseignant
et les gens qui construisent les
programmes c'est la raison pour laquelle
on a demandé à pouvoir continuer à
conserver cette
spécificité vous avez posé une question
sur IOD
donc la directive européenne bon moi je
voudrais dire ici de manière très claire
que l'élevage français n'est pas un
élevage industriel au regard de ce qui
se pratique sur le reste de la planète
bon et que il y a une forme
d'incompréhension donc là encore que que
l'on demande un certain nombre
d'encadrement de cadre de normes c'est
tout à fait normal mais faisons constat
quand même que nos élevages sont des
élevages qui n'ont rien à voir avec ce
qu'on observe en Chine en Russie en
Argentine que si on veut là aussi
permettre qu'on qu'on continue à porter
l'ambition de l'élevage il faut quand
même être un peu raisonnable je suis en
mal de vous répondre définitivement
puisque ce sujet est toujours en
discussion à Bruxelles alors les seuils
qui étaient descendus très bas qui sont
pas les mêmes en fonction si on est en
bovins en porcin ou en volaille ne sont
pas je fais mais pour nous l'ambition
c'est de faire en sorte qu'on les relève
le plus possible possible encore une
fois pour des élevages qui pour la
plupart d'entre eux sont des élevages
familiaux et qui seront transmis donc
l'idée c'est pas de faire de la
paperasse maintenant qui est un suivi
sanitaire réglementaire c'est déjà le
cas et c'est normal et pour assurer la
traçabilité mais en revanche laisser à
penser parce que c'est pas tant le mode
opératoire que ce que ça laisse à penser
qu'on aurait des élevages industriels
avec cette espèce de marronnier autour
de l'élevage industriel alors que il
suffit de voyager un peu pour constater
ce qu'est la réalité d'élevage français
me paraît pas enclin et à promouvoir ce
qu'on souhaite nous c'est à dire
l'attractivité des nouvelles générations
sur vos questions madame ça sonne sur le
la prédation alors c'est le sujet qui
est en train de monter très fortement en
ce moment
un vieux sujet notamment quand on est
dans le Mercantour et vous le savez
mieux que moi mais là où on avait
quelques départements concernés il y a
une dizaine d'années on est en train de
d'observer une explosion du front de
colonisation
alors je veux être mesuré dans mon
propos mais c'est insupportable pour les
éleveurs insupportable pour les éleveurs
de ne pas vous pouvoir aller vous
coucher sans vous dire que vous allez
vous lever le lendemain matin avec une
partie de votre production c'est c'est
moi j'ai vu des gens dans des situations
psychiques intenables voilà avec malgré
tout des solutions inadaptées de
claustration d'animaux de chiens avec
les problématiques du chien avec les
voisins enfin voilà mais là on est en
train de changer de dimension puisque
maintenant les Francs de colonisation en
Côte-d'Or dans la Nièvre en
Saône-et-Loire ce sont des attaques sur
des bovins et les bovins on va pas avec
le stress tous les soirs je
pardonnez-moi si j'ai oublié des
départements il y en a enfin de façon le
loup est en train de collier et donc là
on ne peut pas un taureau d'une tonne
100 a été attaqué dans l'Yonne la
semaine dernière bon donc on est plus du
tout dans le même niveau et on ne
rentrera pas les animaux tous les soirs
enfin il faut absolument ne rien
connaître à ce métier pour considérer
qu'on rentrera les animaux tous les
soirs bon donc en fait maintenant on est
au pied du mur c'est à dire que là on
expliquait qu'il y avait des solutions
avec les ovins solutions inacceptables
je le redis et voilà quel est le sujet
et la position de la FNSEA ça n'est pas
de dire on veut zéro loup là aussi je
veux être équilibré le plan national du
loup que vous connaissez madame prévoit
l'objectif de 500 loup qui permet de
maintenir la race les derniers comptages
de l'ofb sont à 971 et je ne dis pas si
c'est un comptage selon la police ou les
manifestants mais nous considérons nous
qu'on est probablement très au-delà
bon mais je respecte le travail des
agents de l'ofb qui nous disent
aujourd'hui 960 c'est-à-dire bien
supérieur ce qui a conduit un certain
nombre de tirs de prélèvement et je m'en
réjouis mais qui doit aller maintenant
plus loin le sujet pour nous c'est que
nous aurons dès demain dans les
Hautes-Alpes au-dessus de Gap un
rendez-vous sur les assises de la
prédation
voilà dans lequel nous souhaitons que
les ministres à la fois de l'agriculture
et Madame Couillard secrétaire d'État
viennent nous expliquer comment ils
entendent faire évoluer le plan loup qui
doit être écrit
avec un préfet coordonnateur
qui de mon point de vue
ne conduit pas complètement l'ambition
qu'il portait c'est-à-dire de dire on
essaie de faire en sorte que les 500
loups soient atteints mais on a besoin
aujourd'hui je le dis non plus d'un plan
de gestion mais d'un plan de régulation
et les monte un sens l'idée de pouvoir
maintenir une population de loups autour
de 500 mais de faire en sorte qu'on
n'est pas une colonisation ça n'est pas
tenable j'ajoute que dans les
financements il y a deux choses il y a
la prévention et il y a évidemment
l'indemnisation pour ce qui est de la
prévention c'est le budget de la
politique agricole commune qui le
finance dans le cadre de la pacte le
deuxième pilier que cette enveloppe
quand on l'a négocié était autour de 35
millions d'euros qu'elle est au moment
où je vous parle le 60 millions d'euros
et que mes récentes discussions avec le
ministère de l'Agriculture les sa pensée
qu'on sera l'année prochaine à 100
millions d'euros nous ne sommes pas sous
contrôle je parle de la prévention avant
même qu'on parle du sujet des bovins
compte à l'indemnisation qui évidemment
légitime elle est évidemment pas à la
hauteur parce que on indemnise les bêtes
tuer mais vous savez que quand vous avez
un troupeau qui a subi une attaque vous
avez des problèmes de prolificité
derrière vous avez des problèmes de
gestion du troupeau enfin donc il y a
les effets induits des attaques qui ne
sont pas supportables dans des métiers
où la rentabilité
quand même plus que modeste bon je
trouve qu'il y a une forme de
condescendance qui est insupportable
pour les éleveurs et donc devant les
parlementaires moi je veux dire très
clairement que il appartient il vous
appartient de dire si oui ou non on
garde un élevage alors à l'époque on
disait un élevage en montagne mais on
parle plus de ça on parle d'un élevage
je vous dis que on a des attaques tous
les jours
j'ai eu un échange avant-hier vendredi
pardon avec le préfet de région de la
région Bourgogne Franche-Comté qui me
dit je suis très inquiet
je suis très inquiet nous ne sommes pas
sous contrôle voilà bon je
dis que cette situation nécessite qu'on
réagisse rapidement et très
volontairement sur la sécheresse
et sur les compteurs pardonnez-moi je ne
suis pas un expert voilà ce que je veux
vous dire c'est que nous nous opposons
pas et encore une fois je vous l'ai dit
je suis élu local il est évidemment
impensable que les habitants n'est pas
accès à de l'eau potable voilà bon moi
qui les gens qui les piscines je suis
ravi pour eux et encore une fois voilà
il appartient à un congère de manière
responsable au et on a eu dans un
certain nombre de départements des
sujets de gestion notamment de l'eau
hivernale qui n'est pas tenable
je prends l'exemple des Pyrénées
Orientales dans lequel il y a eu de
largage d'eau cet hiver et puis on se
retrouve un peu court là avec des
questions de débit d'eau réservés pour
maintenir une forme de biodiversité et
dans lequel la question agricole doit
être aussi
nous ce qu'on défend c'est le fait que
l'eau agricole pour produire de
l'alimentation reste
prioritaire en tous les cas au même
niveau que les sujets ayant fait au flux
d'eau pour la biodiversité voilà ce
qu'on dit je veux rappeler aussi qu'il y
a des efforts et de la sobriété à
consentir on en est tout à fait d'accord
et que quand on a eu ce sujet dans les
pierres orientales les arboriculteurs
avaient réduit de 75% leur consommation
donc on est dans des efforts qui sont
massifs l'objet étant de préserver le
fond c'est à dire la vie des arbres on
est plus sur les fruits
donc nous sommes très favorables à
avancer sur les paiements pour services
environnementaux on est là aussi très
favorable tout ce qui peut être
contributif pour le faire et d'ailleurs
je le dis les collectivités locales et
territoriales peuvent être des appuis
intéressants dans le déploiement de ses
services ça a commencé je le dis trop
trop doucement mais vous parliez
d'épitaire donc l'ancienne présidente de
la FNSEA Cristiano Lambert est resté la
présidente d’épitter et on continue à
porter cette ambition en accompagnement
avec le carbone puisque nous avons aussi
une structure dans lequel on veut
proposer des crédit carbone et faire en
sorte que les entreprises qui cherchent
à décarboner leur activité puissent
trouver à la fois ces fameux PSE et à la
fois des crédits carbone français de
proximité pour le faire
je poursuis pardonnez-moi si mes
réponses sont très courtes sur la Savoie
pardonnez-moi madame donc
même réponse sur l'élevage et on
continue à pousser très fort
on a notamment dans vos départements des
sujets qui sont encore plus dramatiques
en ce moment avec du dérochement enfin
voilà donc je pense que ça va faire
l'objet d'une discussion et on attend
des décisions sur l'attractivité des
métiers et notamment vous parler
d'arboriculture qui est pas une
spécificité de la département même si
c'est le cas chez vous mais c'est le cas
bien dans bien des départements qui sont
à la recherche de main d'oeuvre je pense
à l'habitude culture je pense à
l'arboriculture on a une vraie crise
d'évocation voilà pour lequel on est on
est on est inquiet alors on essaie de
développer l'attractivité je veux dire
aussi que les conditions d'hébergement
les conditions de rémunération ont aussi
été travaillés pour permettre que on le
lève mais aujourd'hui la solution vient
essentiellement de travailleurs
étrangers qui viennent pour des saisons
que ce soit des pays de l'Est que ce
soit du Maroc on a des contrats aux
filles qu'on avec les services
concernés enfin tout ce qui permet
demain de continuer à produire on a
aujourd'hui des producteurs qui
renoncent à développer leur ferme ou
leur production faute de combattants
pour pour ramasser et pour faire les
choses donc c'est c'est un vrai sujet de
préoccupation par ailleurs l'agriculture
le monde agricole un développe des des
de la promotion des métiers enfin il y a
tout un tas de de choses qui sont faites
mais je reconnais que il reste beaucoup
à faire monsieur le sénateur abbé sur la
viande in vitro alors je voudrais très
clairement et très précisément vous dire
ce qui est la position de l'iPhone et
soit qui au regard des commentaires qui
ont été faits dans la presse et je
remercie monsieur le sénateur Hitman
d'avoir précisé les choses mais je veux
le faire devant vous la FNSEA est
totalement et clairement opposé à la
production de viande in vitro pour des
raisons je crois tout le monde peut
comprendre qui tiennent à notre aspect
identitaire culturelle productif voilà
donc s'il y avait une ambiguïté je vous
prie d'entendre qu'elle est totalement
levée elle a été reprécisée par le
conseil d'administration de l'effetsea
il y a quelques jours et elle ne souffre
pas l'ambiguïté mais une fois que j'ai
dit ça et j'ai dit clairement que nous
étions contre j'observe et ça a été dit
que c'est le cadre européen qui opèrent
aujourd'hui et donc la question c'est
pas simplement d'être contre c'est que
sommes-nous en mesure de faire pour que
le développement de ces productions soit
pour nous
idéalement empêché mais je sais pas si
on y arrivera mais en tous les cas très
encadré et surtout qu'on explique ce
qu'est la réalité à la fois des
financements qui pour la plupart d'entre
eux ne sont pas des financements
européens
à la fois la réalité du bilan carbone de
cette production qu'on est en train de
regarder très précisément et qui n'est
pas du tout ce qu'on veut bien nous
vendre voilà donc voilà j'espère que mes
propos ont suffi à lever les vitibilité
c'est-à-dire c'est un nom clair massif
et franc et c'est pas seulement une fois
qu'on a dit non maintenant c'est clair
et on arrête c'est aussi quel est le
combat à mener pour que l'objectif que
nous nous sommes fixés
on n'est pas des digues qui sautent à
tous les étages et disons-le à Bruxelles
il y a un courant marqué entre on va
dire une DG trade une DG qui s'occupe du
commerce qui est très
tourné vers le libre-échange et de
l'autre côté ce que je vous ai dit c'est
à dire une nécessaire régulation que
nous portons qui n'empêche pas les
échanges mais qui ne doit pas faire
preuve de naïveté sur la PAC
vous avez raison j'en ai peu parlé parce
que c'est un sujet que je considère un
tout petit peu derrière nous même si la
mise en oeuvre est maintenant sur le
Green Deal nous avons été clair il y a
un certain nombre d'enjeux du Green Deal
qui sont d'une actualité brûlante je
veux parler des aspects du dérèglement
climatique des aspects de la
biodiversité mais par rapport à la
production du Green Deal il y a un
certain d'éléments exogènes je pense
notamment la guerre qui ont redistribué
les cartes ce que nous n'acceptons pas
nous c'est la baisse de l'ambition de
production qui je redis n'est pas du
productivisme mais qui est la nécessité
que les européens continuent à se
saisir de ce sujet je pense que
l'exemple récent que nous avons vécu sur
la question énergétique avec la Russie
qui nous tenait Rennes courte et les
sujets alimentaires sur l'Afrique
doivent nous amener collectivement à
prendre conscience que nous devons
absolument dans le cadre du Green Deal
ne pas renoncer à l'ambition qui nous
concerne tous
des solutions et des réponses aux
dérèglement climatique et la réduction
des émissions à la biodiversité à sa
restauration mais de l'autre ne pas
renoncer et nous on pense que c'est
possible
sans renoncer aux ambitions
environnementales et aux attentes
sociétales ça sera un challenge
difficile mais nous ne devons pas y
renoncer sauf à considérer que on
laissera d'autres produire ce qui
m'amène à vous parler des échanges alors
quand je disais il y a plus des songes
en tous les cas ceux qui demeurent sont
des choses dont on parle depuis plus de
25 ans pour le reste on a plutôt des
achats des échanges
bilatéraux le multilat latéralisme a
quand même un peu vécu bon et ça fera
écho au sénateur qui est parti mais qui
parlait du Mercosur notamment bon là
aussi essayons d'être équilibré
l'agriculture a des intérêts offensifs
et défensifs
elle a notamment sur le vin et sur les
produits laitiers plutôt des intérêts
offensifs mais on a des intérêts très
défensifs notamment sur l'élevage et
l'avion bovine et que vu sa situation il
faut faire les ovins aussi il faut faire
des choix je le dis tout le monde parle
le Mercosur la semaine dernière
l'Australie a obtenu un quota
d'importation de viande de 24000 tonnes
en franchise de doigts de douane en
Europe donc je veux dire que en même
temps que le rapport sortait tout tout
ça voilà bon il faut qu'à un moment on
soit cohérent je voudrais vous donner
les chiffres je ne renonce pas à aucun
moment au plan au Plan National
Nutrition Santé qui est un bien public
sur lequel il faut qu'on soit
collectivement vigilant et je n'ignore
pas les problèmes d'obésité ou
malnutrition je dis simplement
qu'on ne peut pas d'un côté nous
expliquer qu'il faudrait réduire la
consommation mieux manger et réduire le
nombre de têtes de bétail et dans le
même temps voir des importations qui ne
cessent d'augmenter moi je vous donne la
réalité des chiffres la réalité des
chiffres c'est que nous consommons en
France environ 1,5 millions de tonnes de
viande bovine ce chiffre est
relativement stable je parle de viande
bovine je ne parle pas de la totalité
des viandes ce chiffre est relativement
stable il varie de quelques pourcents
c'est à dire que ça n'est pas
significatif il a tendance à baisser
père capita mais le volume total et le
même
en revanche ce qui augmente beaucoup
c'est les importations on est on a passé
le stade des 400.000 tonnes importés
donc on est à 25% d'importation novions
bovine et et là je vous le dis 25% c'est
avec aussi ce qu'on exporte on fait un
petit peu de viande sur l'Italie les
broutards un peu sur l'Algérie soldes
c'est 25%. et ça ne cesse d'augmenter
donc expliquer qu'on va pouvoir qu'il
faudrait pardonner moi réduire sa
consommation de viande certainement pour
ceux qui en consomment trop de l'autre
réduire un cheptel français alors qu'on
ne cesse dans n'importe quel plus et que
la consommation globale ne change pas
c'est pardonnez-moi inacceptable pour le
président de la FNSEA et donc on a
besoin d'être très clair et dans le même
temps évidemment nous expliquer qu'on va
faire des accords et qu'on va importer
cette semaine c'est pas une décision
française c'est une décision bruxelloise
24000 tonnes de viande bovine
d'Australie en franchise le doigts de
douane quand vous êtes éleveur vous vous
dites c'est c'est enfin au moins qu'on
ait le courage politique de nous dire
qu'on est un secteur d'ajustement et
puis au moins on sera clair mais là ça
n'est pas assumé c'est fait
insidieusement et c'est insupportable
donc j'ai entendu des propos de la
première ministre hier à l'Assemblée
nationale une ligne claire je veux
croire que cette ligne sera tenue mais
il va falloir aussi qu'on ait quelques
gages que cette ligne n'est pas
simplement un propos de tribune
sur
les EnR les petites unités de
méthanisation donc oui
nous on se bat pour qu'on puisse avoir
des unités agricoles voilà et on est
on n'est pas complètement aligné avec
les grands énergéticiens qui sont en
train de travailler à des unités de
grande taille on oppose pas les unités
de grande taille nous on dit simplement
on veut pas être la variable
d'ajustement et on ne veut pas se
retrouver avec des situations où on nous
expliquerait que simplement les grands
universitiens font ça je pense qu'ils
ont besoin de ça et ils ont surtout
besoin des terres agricoles pour les
plans d'épandage et ça on va pas laisser
les choses se faire sans qu'on ait
encore une fois le sujet de fond c'est
la valeur ajoutée je veux dire aussi un
petit mot parce que je sais que parfois
la méthanisation peut s'opposer dans
certains territoires avec l'élevage sur
l'accès un certain nombre de produits
nous on est très équilibré à l'iPhone et
ce soir on considère que la
méthanisation c'est comme le reste des
projets de territoire et que la réalité
des territoires n'est pas la même
partout et donc on oppose pas les
productions on dit simplement que il
faut une forme de complémentarité et que
dans certaines zones d'élevage on a vu
des choses se faire qu'on ne valide pas
je le dis aller chercher de l'ensilage à
des distances parfois déraisonnable ou
payer des prix qui sont hors du marché
n'est pas tenable et dessert la
méthanisation agricole en revanche la
situation n'est pas la même partout il y
a des endroits où la tension n'est pas
le même nature et donc il ne faut pas
s'empêcher de développer la
méthanisation agricole on aura aussi si
le gouvernement porte la volonté besoin
d'éclairer les aspects réglementaires
qui sont aujourd'hui intenables et vous
savez que la méthanisation est arrêtée
en tous les cas la plupart des projets
parce que soit l'écoute de construction
soit les coûts de rachat ne permettent
plus aujourd'hui des équipes de projet
sur la question
du sénateur grimier sur la relation
qu'on soit alimentation citoyen alors
nous on porte une ambition claire c'est
de réaffirmer que trop longtemps
l'alimentation était considérée comme
une commodité
et nous ce qu'on dit c'est que les
Français doivent aujourd'hui accepter
même si ça n'est pas facile les Français
doivent accepter de payer le juste prix
du modèle alimentaire qu'il souhaite
avoir je l'ai dit 13%
13% ça n'est pas tenable
18%, ça n'est pas pour le consommateur
vous m'avez interpellé monsieur le
sénateur je dis dans votre région par le
Midi Libre qui me voilà donc je me
balade toujours avec un faux billet de
100 euros dans lequel il y a la part
agricole
tout le reste c'est des coûts de
transformation de logistique de modèles
social et de distribution donc on a
l'habitude de m'interroger pour dire qui
en profite mais moi je dis l'agriculture
est très transparente on a on a fait ça
de manière transparente on explique
alors le 690 est une moyenne bien
entendu et que le reste ça n'est pas
nous on nous a interrogé récemment je
rappelle que dans une baguette de pain
qui vaut 1 Euro 5 en moyenne en France
le blé représente 7 centimes voilà bon
donc je pourrais vous parler bon donc on
a besoin là d'être très clair sur le
fait que il y a un certain nombre de
marge il y a eu un rapport de
l'Inspection des Finances qui a été fait
il y a un an et demi maintenant qui
montrait que égali m'avait permis de
rétablir un peu de marge en exploitation
agricole de l'or 25% on était à 9%
dans la nature alimentaire et la grande
distribution avait encore ça parle du
gâteau moi je n'oppose pas puisque dans
un système on a besoin de tout le monde
et 90% des gens
consomment dans les grandes surfaces ce
que nous disons nous c'est que la guerre
des prix et l'idée que on pourrait être
toujours le plus bas avec un modèle
social auquel nous tenons tous n'est pas
tenable pour le maillon de la production
c'est clair et net on l'a toujours dit
je le redis devant vous et je veux que
cela soit su et j'œuvre depuis que je
suis arrivé pour expliquer à la grande
distribution qui commence à se poser des
questions d'approvisionnement et je
pense notamment la viande bovine qui
commence à se poser qui est sur
l'approvisionnement que la
contractualisation pourrait avoir du
sens et dans le petit jeu récent qui
nous a tous
occupé sur les radios depuis un mois sur
qui à la marge je veux dire que bon il y
a quand même un jeu enfin je veux dire
un mot du chèque alimentaire puisque
c'est ce que nous avions demandé nous
étant très conscient qu'un certain
nombre encore une fois de français ne
mangent pas leurs faim ce sujet a été
fermé il y a 100 millions de plus qui
ont été mis auprès des banques
alimentaires qui est une goutte d'eau
dans le besoin réel de ces associations
mais encore une fois nous nous ne
voulons pas la réouverture de la guerre
des prix
le ministre de l'Économie Monsieur le
Maire a mis tout son poids politique je
l'ai moi-même inter publiquement
interrogé pour dire si des gens
exagèrent dites nous qui le sont mais
arrêtons cette espèce de cirque qui
consiste à dire c'est pas moi c'est
l'autre tout ça ne me paraît pas très au
regard des enjeux ne me paraît pas très
durable en tous les cas nous pour ce qui
nous concerne nous avons envie de
proposer aux consommateurs une
alimentation française de qualité et
c'est aussi pour ça que nous nous
battons pour la traçabilité pour
l'étiquetage pour l'origine
sur les sujets
lames de fond élevage est répondu sur
les contrats formation
il nous paraît évident que ça fait
d'ailleurs éco j'avais pas complètement
répondu monsieur le sénateur sur le fait
que on attire des jeunes dans nos
exploitations et qu'on puisse leur faire
faire des choses aujourd'hui vous prenez
un jeune en alternance qui a 16 ans on
agriculture il y a plein de choses qui
sont pas possibles et souvent ça
commence par un contrôle de l'inspection
du travail pour être très clair bon on
peut pas considérer que ce soit
extrêmement incitatif voilà donc
beaucoup de gens renoncent
c'est
les charges lourdes c'est le bruit c'est
le travail en hauteur c'est voilà alors
il s'agit pas non plus évidemment quand
on accueille des jeunes l'idée c'est
d'être très précautionneux de faire
monter en compétences donc on peut pas
tout faire dès le premier jour enfin si
vous prenez un stagiaire dont l'objectif
est de vous regarder toute la journée
c'est évidemment ça limite un peu un peu
la trait mais je sais que l'inspection
du travail tient beaucoup à son
indépendance que je respecte je dis
simplement qu'à un moment si on veut
faire que les gens se rencontrent il
faut aussi peut-être un petit peu
adapter les dispositifs
sur la filière pomme de terre madame la
sénatrice nous sommes très conscients de
la situation difficile qu'elle traverse
alors qui tient en gros au mot de
l'agriculture de manière générale c'est
à dire des problèmes de compétitivité
vous savez que nos amis belges ont
aujourd'hui les usines de transformation
amène les produits les contrats et les
camions l'agriculture française produit
les produits quand elle le peut et la
valeur ajoutée est faite ailleurs ça
n'est pas tenable nous avons alerté à
multiples reprises on a aussi en
production de pommes de terre des sujets
de plans on a des sujets de stockage
dans les stockages froids avec des
matières actives qui ont disparu et qui
ne permet plus une conservation
optimisée de la pomme de terre bon donc
alors que on est un des pays européens
les les plus les plus forts en
production et que c'était un avantage
compétitif notamment dans vos régions
voilà on est en train une fois de plus
dans ce secteur de père de la
compétitivité ça pouvez pas tenable vous
parliez des betteraves sucrières je ne
veux pas rouvrir le chapitre des
néoclinicotinoïdes dont on attend parler
mais là aussi je vous le dis on est en
pleine période de pucerons nous serons
dans quelques semaines si oui ou non il
y a de la jaunisse ce que je peux vous
dire c'est que si on a de la jaunisse de
manière importante on aura des
fermetures de sites industriels on aura
de la réduction de production parce que
ça n'est pas tenable et donc cette
production viendra d'Allemagne de
Pologne pour l'agriculteur que je suis
ça n'est pas évidemment encendable
sur l'urgence de l'eau je crois que j'ai
répondu sur les souverainetés
alimentaires les équilibres vous avez
raison je regarde qui m'a posé la
question pardonnez-moi
oui c'était les importations et
notamment les sujets du cycle de la zone
je vais en dire un mot nous sommes
dépendants pour une certaine mesure de
l'importation pardonnez-moi de
l'importation de d'azote d'où notre
préoccupation de pouvoir bénéficier
d'abord de l'azote organique qui est le
donc là aussi vous voyez bien les effets
de bordure si je puis dire qui sont même
plus des bordures quand on parle de
cycles des productions et et de là aussi
de la dépendance nous travaillons avec
le gouvernement un certain nombre de
solutions notamment pour décarboner la
production d'azote en termes de
pollution l'azote c'est 20% la
production et 40 % et 80% pardon les
pendages et donc nous travaillons aussi
au niveau agricole pour que
l'enfouissement et les épandages soient
améliorés pour réduire l'ambition de
l'émission enfin pardon pas réduire
l'ambition de l'émission réduire
l'impact de nos émissions et pouvoir
remplir l'ambition qui est la nôtre
en Allemagne sur les fournitures de
stock nous nous sommes favorables on l'a
dit on l'a au moment notamment du covid
a des stocks de sécurité pour le moment
ça n'est pas au goût du jour pour les
aspects essentiellement budgétaires
certains y voit le retour d'une forme de
de de gestion de la puissance publique
et ça rappellera l'intervention sur les
céréales que qui a disparu depuis de
nombreuses années mais ce sujet de toute
façon reviendra dans le débat public à
un moment ou un autre
vous parliez de continuité monsieur le
sénateur voilà sur les pertes de 100 000
actifs de 80% de disparition de la
biodiversité
j'espère que vous avez compris dans mes
propos que quand je parlais de
continuité c'était de l'ambition
agricole française et non pas de la
perte du nombre d'agriculteurs ni même
de l'impact sur la biodiversité je veux
dire aussi que
je lis de 6 dollars qui auraient une
forme de négation de l'impact de
l'agriculture telle qu'elle se pratique
je n'ai jamais tenu ses propos et je ne
les tiendrai jamais je pense qu'on n'est
jamais plus efficace que quand on est
lucide sur la réalité des impacts qui
sont les siens ce que je dis c'est que
les transitions sont en cours que la
volonté d'essayer d'accompagner tout ce
qui permet de restaurer la biodiversité
et portée par la FNSEA on a parlé
d'épiteurs je veux parler de la haie un
instant s'il veut mieux autoriser j'ai
dit aux mises de l'agriculture que ceux
qui bloquaient sur les c'est la
pénalisation de la haie il y a des
endroits où il y a de la haie
et il faut la conserver mais il y a les
endroits c'est notamment le cas de ma
région où il n'y a historiquement pas de
haies je n'en ai jamais connu mon père
non plus
et je trouve que l'intérêt ce serait
d'en remettre là mais quelle est la
compréhension pour un agriculteur de
dire tu vas planter des parce que ça du
sens pour la biodiversité parce que ça
du sens pour l'agronomie parce que ça du
sens pour l'érosion des sols parce que
ça a du sens de le faire quand vous
savez que le premier maître que vous
avez planté vous êtes ficelé pour les 50
prochaines années et ben moi j'essaye
d'expliquer à tous les ministres qui
passent que le jour où dira aux gens
faites-le ça a du sens de le faire et si
jamais vous en avez 10 ou 50 mètres à
faire sauter de toute façon il n'existe
pas donc moi je plaide pour la clause
grand-père qui permettrait de dire ce
qui existe le garde dans le contexte
actuel mais si on veut un coût
d'accélérateur et faire en sorte que ça
libère les gens et bien il faut qu'on
lève le cadre
ce sera possible ou pas ça vous
appartient puisque c'est du cadre
législatif notamment c'est aussi des
aspects bruxellois sur les directives
oiseaux sur tout ça mais ça a du sens de
le faire donc entendez les mêmes propos
la volonté d'accompagner ce mouvement
j'appartiens à une génération qui est
conscient des impacts qui ont été faits
par l'agriculture dans les 50 dernières
années et qui n'est pas hors sol voilà
en revanche il faut trouver l'équilibre
entre la nécessité de conserver
l'attractivité du métier les productions
dans des modèles de production qui
peuvent être très différents et donc on
est aussi très hostile à ce qu'on nous
dise le vôtre modèle moi si vous savez
quel est mon modèle ça m'intéresse
beaucoup parce que au quotidien en
fonction des départements puisque j'ai
reçu de nombreux invitations je peux
vous prouver très facilement que vos
agriculteurs sont très diverses en
fonction de là où vous trouvez mais il y
a une volonté manifeste et nous l'avons
écrit de faire en sorte qu'on soit plus
ouvert sur les attentes sociétales et
qu'on puisse faire muter le modèle pour
peu que les agriculteurs gagnent leur
vie puissent continuer
à entreprendre parce que c'est important
pour nous de le faire et de le faire de
manière responsable
[Musique]
et que
ce que on traverse en ce moment monde
quand même la difficulté pour un certain
nombre de consommateurs à pouvoir avoir
accès à la culture biologique y compris
pour des gens qui le font et moi je vous
le dis aussi si c'est de l'agriculture
biologique important ça ne me satisfait
pas voilà donc on n'a pas de problème à
développer l'agriculture biologique on
le fait je voudrais rappeler que la
FNSEA est le syndicat qui regroupe le
plus de producteurs en agriculture
biologiques que je n'oppose pas les
systèmes mais que après il y a quand
même des réalités de vente avec je le
dis en passant des niveaux de marge en
termes de distribution qui nous ont
aussi interrogé bien donc j'essaie de
voir le coup problème dans sa complétude
mais au moment où je vous parle on a un
urgent besoin de stabiliser la
problématique biologique pourquoi parce
qu'on assiste au moment où je parle de
la déconversion qui est
pas une bonne nouvelle pour l'iPhone et
ce soir pas une bonne nouvelle pour le
consommateur et pas une bonne nouvelle
pour nous tous parce que quand vous avez
quelqu'un qui met de l'énergie qui met
des moyens qui développent et puis qui a
un moment se fait casser les ailes
puisque nous notre vocation c'est
d'accompagner les gens qu'on goût
d'entreprendre on agriculture biologique
ou ailleurs ça n'est pas une bonne
nouvelle et donc nous ce qu'on veut
c'est pas développer avec des
pourcentages qu'on nous annonce qui ne
sont pas tenables à ce stade c'est faire
en sorte qu'on ne perd pas de terrain on
a quelque chose logique on stabilise les
choses pour permettre que quand la
consommation va reprendre quand
l'inflation la consommation qui a baissé
de 8,6% sur les six derniers mois et que
on reprenne un cycle que l'on espère
plus serein alors on soit capable de
relancer la dynamique mais aujourd'hui
convertir des jeunes en agriculture
biologique dans le lait par exemple
alors que le marché saturé et que les
gens cachent du lait biologique le
revend donc conventionnel ça n'a pas de
sens voilà donc il faut le faire aussi
de manière non idéologique si je puis
dire et assez équilibré en coordination
avec le marché enfin les relations avec
les organismes lancent inrae avec
landeces dans les derniers temps assez
peu de relation parce que comme il y
avait des petits sujets on a plutôt pris
nos distances mais sinon d'une manière
régulière pour comprendre alors là aussi
je voudrais très précis sur la position
de la fnse1 nous avons besoin d'un
organisme indépendant qui produisent de
la donnée scientifique
nous avons besoin d'un pouvoir politique
qui assume des décisions politiques
c'est ce que président de la République
a fait dans le cadre du covid avec un
conseil de défense sanitaire et des
décisions politiques
donc le reste je laisse la polémique
nous n'avons à la FNSEA pas attaquer
l'anceste je n'ai publiquement jamais
tenu propos de cette nature et je vais
être très précis sur les propos que je
tiens sur
l'avenir la terre sur le photovoltaïque
monsieur le sénateur est parti
à pardonnez-moi pardonnez-moi
pardonnez-moi
donc là aussi nous on est on est dans
l'ensemble du spectre donc on a dit que
le photovoltaiko sol n'était pas
étrangers au photovoltaïques sur les
toits les toitures voilà mais il y a un
sujet d'échelle acceptons-le bien donc
nous on oppose pas ce qu'on veut et on
est très vigilant parce que les décrets
d'application sont en discussion en ce
moment et on va les regarder de très
très près ce qu'on veut pas je l'ai dit
tout à l'heure c'est fait en sorte qu'on
perde de la production agricole et qu'en
fait on essaie une espèce de Man dans
lequel ce serait le nouvel eldorado je
vous ai expliqué que on portait plutôt
des projets collectifs et que nous ce
qu'on voulait c'était que la part des
volu à l'agriculture ne soit pas une
petite portion quelques miettes mais que
on soit très vigilant et ensuite vous
inquiétez pas on saura le réparti entre
le monde agricole la perte aussi la
perte d'exploitation
vécue avec la perte de volume dans un
certain nombre d'industries de
transformation j'y pense et de faire en
sorte qu'on ait le moins de paires
possibles là on est dans le moment
critique où on va figer la doxa et il
faut qu'on soit nous extrêmement
vigilant et je vous prie de croire qu'on
le saura
sur les 6,90 €, je vous ai répondu
sur les traités de libre-échange je
crois que j'en ai dit un mot sur les
clauses miroirs bon alors close miroir
versus miroir aux alouettes
ce qui est sûr c'est que nous on sera on
sera très vigilant
sur au moins les contrôles je vais vous
en dire un mot parce qu'on parle
beaucoup de libre-échange mais il se
trouve qu'il y a des échanges qui qui
existent et qu'aujourd'hui les contrôles
opérés sont extrêmement faibles avec des
moyens extrêmement faibles et les les
sons de cloche qui nous reviennent sont
que les non-conformités sont de plus en
plus importantes notamment sur la viande
bovine
bon donc moi je dis je veux bien qu'on
parle du futur et de la manière dont on
va échanger avec le reste de Planète
j'aimerais juste qu'on déjà on mesure ce
qui est la réalité aujourd'hui des
échanges et les sujets qui nous
concernent tout le monde sait
aujourd'hui que par important de viande
bobine importée c'est Allemagne Pays-Bas
et que pour une partie de cette viande
elle n'est pas d'origine allemande ou
des Pays-Bas donc voilà je dis
simplement qu'on a besoin de mieux
contrôler et de mettre plus de moyens
sur la réalité sanitaire de ces
conditions de réciprocité après la FNSEA
n'est pas naïve tout le monde est
conscient de la réelle politique on a vu
les États-Unis la Chine sans
ce que relai à coup de d'aluminium de
d'acier de soja voilà donc
penser que l'Europe éclairera de sa
suffisance le reste de la planète me
paraît peu crédible en revanche on a
besoin de continuer à commercer et de
veiller au moins pour un certain nombre
de molécules et de choses interdites en
Europe qu'on ne fasse pas la courte
échelle aux produits je le dis
d'ailleurs notamment sur les produits
alimentaires qui vont être aidés dans le
cadre des financements de la solidarité
si l'argent public français peut
bénéficier à des produits français ça
nous paraîtrait de bonne aloi
par exemple
[Musique]
sur in vitro je crois que j'ai répondu
sur la souveraineté énergétique et usage
alimentaire non alimenté un question de
du sénateur Kuypers bon là aussi on
entend beaucoup de choses la vocation de
l'agriculture c'est de nourrir
pour autant l'agriculture a toujours
réservé une part de sa production à
l'énergie
petite parenthèse de l'air pétrole et
encore voilà aujourd'hui je voudrais
vous dire que les surfaces consacrées à
la production d'énergie c'est moins de
5% à l'arrivée de la méthanisation peut
se challenger mais comme il y a une
partie énergie et une partie de
production parce qu'on fait trois
production 2 ans bon on peut discuter
des chiffres en tous les cas ça n'est
pas significatif je vais vous dire
l'enjeu entre l'alimenter et non
alimentaire il va vite tomber parce que
l'objectif commun de l'ensemble de
l'agriculture au profit de la Société ça
va être la production de biomasse et
c'est ça qui va nous permettre d'être
contributeur
à la réduction des émissions gaz à effet
de serre et donc on aura besoin de
produire de la biomasse y compris des
cultures intermédiaires à valorisation
énergétique ou pas donc nos a seulement
vont évoluer et on va le faire je
n'oppose pas pour ma part les différents
énergies avec le mix je vais vous dire
quand même un mot de biocarburant je
m'en voudrais de venir ici de ne pas
l'aborder sujet
nous avons aujourd'hui des biocarbures
première génération qui font des bas
d'abord les biocarbures en première
génération pour partie qu'aux produisent
des produits dont de la protéine dont
nous avons un impérieux besoin c'est
tout le plan protéines portées par le
Président de la République porté depuis
longtemps d'une moindre dépendance de
nos soinsetés qui permettraient de
réduire le soja notamment les soja
parfois d'origine des forestantes pas
systématiquement mais en tous les cas de
faire que on soit capable de renverser
la tendance dans laquelle on est donc on
coproduit des choses deuxièmement il y a
des sujets industriels je veux vous dire
ici que une usine de biocarburant de
première génération vaut de l'ordre de
150 millions d'euros une usine de
biocarburant de deuxième génération qui
n'existe pas aujourd'hui il y a un
pilote avec le monde agricole total les
grands de l'énergie vaut de l'ordre de 1
milliard d'euros il y a des sujets
d'équilibre économique évidemment
évident que chacun comprend dans un
modèle dans lequel on n'est pas avancé
et on aura des objectifs je pense
notamment au fuel aérien voilà
contribution
au safetable
donc on a besoin à viach and fioul on a
besoin de de vraiment regarder le
spectre complet donc je n'oppose pas
encore une fois la méthanisation les
biocarburants ceux qui devrait nous
rassembler demain c'est la production
biomasse évidemment pour nourrir voilà
pour contribuer à l'indépendance
énergétique pour faire en sorte que au
plus près des territoires avec des
modèles qui seront différents donc il y
a pas un modèle vu de Paris qui le One
fit soul ça ne marche pas en agriculture
et on a besoin de le faire de manière
apaisée en comprenant bien quels sont
les coproduits et comment on le fait je
le dis parce qu'on aura aussi des
répartitions la biomasse quand on
regarde aujourd'hui elle est comptée
deux fois trois fois tout le monde dit
il y aura assez de biomasse non il va en
manquer il va en manquer donc il faudra
dire où on la met et comment on le fait
et on aura besoin de tout le monde parce
que le concours de la volonté publique
d'un retour du nucléaire ne se frappe au
mieux pas avant une quinzaine d'années
voilà et donc qu'est-ce qu'on fait dans
ces 15 ans or on a des objectifs de
décarbonation d'ici 2030 c'est ce que
nous dit la première ministre voilà donc
ne commençons pas à tirer sur tel ou tel
énergie utilisons tous les moyens dont
nous avons à disposition si on peut
faire évoluer le modèle on le fera bien
volontiers par ailleurs je lis notamment
pour les tracteurs agricoles qui
fonctionnent aujourd'hui avec du GNR
avec une niche fiscale conséquente qui
fait l'objet de discussion régulière
avec le mystère de avec Bercy avec le
ministère de l'économie et des finances
nous pensons nous que demain des
discussions avec les constructeurs
peut-être nous permettront d'être plus
efficace en termes d'économie circulaire
d'apporter des solutions de territoire
en termes de distribution en termes
d'impact environnemental en termes de
stockage et de normes puisque ça n'est
pas un produit pétrolier à proprement
parler il existe des multiplicités de
solutions la question c'est quelle est
la volonté politique et quel est le
niveau d'investissement et assez
conditions là si on a une ligne partagée
assumer avec la continuité des
politiques publiques je le dis parce que
ces types d'investissement ne peut pas
se faire avec un coup de barre à droite
ou à gauche en fonction des alternances
politiques alors je pense qu'on sera en
capacité de relever le challenge merci
beaucoup madame la Présidente merci
infiniment monsieur le président
pour ce tour complet ces deux heures
d'audition merci infiniment
c'était un premier round il y aura bien
des sujets qui vont nous réunir mais
vraiment merci beaucoup merci Arnaud
merci à vous